Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Sendung 22 zum Thema Politik, Korruption, Lobbyismus.
Wir werden heute ein wenig auch über Wulff und die Piraten reden, wie es sich gehört. Vielleicht sollten wir kurz noch ein bisschen erklären, warum es so lange kein Alternativlos gab. Zum einen hatten wir da so diverse technische Probleme, die im Wesentlichen daraus resultieren, dass wir derzeit gerade auf zwei unterschiedlichen Kontinenten sind und sozusagen das Setup, um aus der Fahne zu rekorden. Wir haben erstmal ausprobieren und einpegeln und testen mussten und hatten dabei so ein paar kleine Rück- und Fehlschläge, die die Sache etwas verzögert haben. Und dann gab es noch so ein paar Krankheiten und ähnliche Seuchen. Aber jetzt sind wir wieder da und hoffen auch den...
Und Erdstrahlen.
Erdstrahlen, genau. Und hoffen jetzt jedenfalls, den bisherigen Publikationsfluss wieder aufzunehmen in der gewohnten Geschwindigkeit. Wir freuen uns natürlich, dass ihr trotzdem so zahlreich geflattert habt. Das könnt ihr gerne natürlich auch wieder tun. Da sind wir doch sehr dankbar. Ja, gab es noch irgendwas in der Hausmeisterfront? Ne, nicht wirklich.
Naja, wir könnten unsern Stolz ausdrücken, dass wir einen Interkontinental-Podcast hier los treten. Weil das ist ja schon nicht selbstverständlich.
Genau, andere Leute haben Interkontinental-Raketen, wir haben Interkontinental-Podcasts.
Also hoffentlich klappt das diesmal.
Also wir haben zwar hohe Hoffnung, aber wissen tut man es erst, wenn es hinterher eingetütet ist. Insofern, ja.
Einflussnahme und Bestechern. Also wir haben eigentlich gedacht, naja, der Wulff bietet sich Korruption an, aber das Thema ist ja ein bisschen weitergehender. Und wir wollen wie immer ein bisschen im historischen Überblick anfangen. Und das Bild des Lobbyisten über die Jahre beleuchten. Früher war das so, dass der Lobbyist so eine Art, was ich nicht Vertreter war, der kam halt bei den Politikern vorbei und hat ihnen eben keine Staubsauger, sondern Ideen verkauft. Hat die dann zum Abendessen eingeladen, mal in den Urlaub mitgenommen, vielleicht den Privatjet ausgeliehen, irgendwie ein Geschenk da, ein Geschenk da.
Ich meine, früher sind die auch zusammen noch in den Puff gegangen und Ähnliches. Also das Wissen...
Ja, natürlich.
Also ich meine, das ist ja auch so ein interessanter Mechanismus, das Wissen um gemeinsame Verstöße gegen irgendwie den postulierten Moralkodex. Das ist natürlich auch immer ein sehr effektives Mittel zur Erreichung von gegensättigen Wünschen und Abhängigkeiten.
Genau, das haben wir auch mal erwähnt, ich glaube in der Sendung zwei oder so, relativ am Anfang. Das ist so, das ist das Fundament, was Geheimgesellschaften zusammenhält. Das Modell hat sich aber weiterentwickelt über die Jahre. Da gab es zwei Stränge. Der erste war die Drehtür. Damit nennt man sowas, wenn Politiker und Lobbyisten eigentlich dieselben Leute sind, die halt ihre Ämter gelegentlich tauschen. Denn Lobbyist ist eine Sache, die kann man beliebig lang machen, aber Politiker, so Beamtsträger insbesondere, das sind ja die interessanten Politiker, es geht ja nicht um alle, sondern es geht um die mit Einfluss. Amtsträger sind ja üblicherweise beschränkt. Da hat man eine Legislaturperiode vor sich. Gut, es gibt auch irgendwelche leitende Beamten, die da auf Lebenszeit sind, aber so die Abgeordneten, die sind üblicherweise nicht für immer da. Und deswegen macht man so Sachen wie, dass man eben guckt, wenn der Beamte oder der Abgeordnete in seiner Tätigkeit günstig für ein Unternehmen abstimmt, dann stellt man ihn danach ein. Und der Punkt dabei ist eben, dass man ihn danach einstellt und nicht davor, weil es dann keine Korruption ist. Wenn man ihm nämlich vorher Geld gibt, dann ist das direkt verboten. Aber wenn man ihm danach einen schönen Job anbietet, was ja die Politiker ansonsten auch gerne selber für sich getan haben, ist eine Lotto-Gesellschaften oder die Aussichtsrat, da sitzen ja die ganzen abgehalfterten Mumien. Das macht eben heute die Industrie.
Die interessante Frage ist ja, warum sind wir denn dahingekommen, dass es jetzt dieses Drehtürmodell gibt? Also so ganz am Anfang war Korruption oder Lobbyismus ja noch ziemlich straightforward. Das sieht man ja heutzutage noch in, ich sage mal, außereuropäischen Ländern, wo dann halt einfach mal so richtig so ein Koffer mit Bargeld auf den Tisch gelegt wird für so eine Bergwerk-Konzession oder für irgendwie anderweitige Gefälligkeiten oder dann halt irgendwie richtig so Grundstücke übereignet werden oder ja, solche Sachen. Und das ist natürlich ein Vorgehen, was mit unserer Ansicht von einer Gesellschaft, also wie sich unsere Gesellschaft selbst betrachtet, nicht so ganz kompatibel ist. Und deswegen hat man halt angefangen, so ein bisschen verdecktere Modelle zu finden, die halt also nicht so irgendwie Bargeldkoffer auf Tisch sind. Und der Grund ist natürlich, dass Einflussnahme in der Politik dazu führt, dass die demokratischen Methoden und Geflogenheiten, die wir so gewohnt sind, ausgehebelt werden. Also dass halt Entscheidungen getroffen werden von Politikern oder beeinflusst werden von Politikern, die eben nichts mit Demokratie zu tun haben. Und nachdem sich nun die Leute dann doch etwas über die Jahrhunderte bzw. ja, doch ja, kann man schon sagen, darüber immer wieder empört haben, dass eben solche Korruption so direkt war und also die Begünstigungen, also was sich irgendwelche Ländereien oder sowas, die dann da ausgehändigt wurden oder zum Teil auch Konzessionen oder Monopole, die vergeben wurden für Wohlgefälligkeit. Und nachdem das dann so ein bisschen so einen schlechten Ruch bekam, fing man dann an, sich so ein bisschen, ja, verdeckter zu bewegen. Und dazu gehören eben dieses, dieses Drehtürmodell.
Wobei so richtig abgelegt haben wir das auch noch nicht. Also ich kann nur mal empfehlen, nach jüdischen Vermächtnissen zu googeln. Auf die CDU wird immer mal gerne mit irgendwelchen Geldkoffern mit innerhalb unklarer Herkunft irgendwo erwischt. Das ist auch nicht völlig vom Tisch bei uns. Aber es ist eben weniger häufig geworden.
Ja, aber das ist durchaus interessant, dass diese Rückfälle es eigentlich dann immer wieder sind, die die Leute so empören, wie jetzt zum Beispiel halt bei unserem Ex-Bundespräsidenten, wo dann eben so 500.000 Euro aus dem Nichts auftauchten und für irgendwie völlig unklare Gegenleistungen ja einfach in die Hand gedrückt werden und als Kredit hinterher deklariert werden.
Und in bar zurückgezahlt, das war ja die Ausrede, so super.
Und so Sachen bar zurückgezahlt und so. Also was wir dabei bei Wulff erlebt haben, ist so ein Rückfall in eben dieses vorzivilisatorische Korruption. Also was man heutzutage auch noch so in diversen osteuropäischen Ländern antreffen kann, wo es dann halt einfach so eine gewisse Struktur gibt, was es sich, wenn man an der Grenze nicht möchte, dass das Auto kontrolliert wird, dann legt man halt irgendwie ein Fofi in den Pass beim Zöllner und dann wird man halt durchgewunken. So und darauf kann man sich auch einigermaßen verlassen. So und da gibt es halt so an, je nach den diversen Grenzen und den Grenzübergängen auch so geradezu schon Tarife, also wie viel man dann wo zu zahlen hat, je nach Volumen des Fahrzeugs und was der Grenzer so vermutet, beziehungsweise der Zöllner, wie viel man da so drin hat. Aber das ist halt irgendwie so eine relativ verlässliche Alltagsschmiererei, die im Wesentlichen dazu dient, das System da am Laufen zu halten. Also die Grenzer verdienen nicht so viel, sind nur die Zöllner und müssen halt von dem Bestechungsgeld dann irgendwie an ihre Oberen abgeben. Und das geht dann eben so weit, dass in einigen Ländern, zum Beispiel der Posten des Innenministers oder des Zollchefs, der wird geradezu versteigert. Also wenn du da diesen Job haben willst, dann musst du schon richtig Geld auf den Tisch legen und die dann halb einem Regierungschef zu zahlen, beziehungsweise an den, der den Regierungschef steuert. Und dementsprechend regeln sich dann die Tarife, weil dieses Investment muss man natürlich irgendwie wieder reinbekommen. Und das funktioniert dann halt eben so, dass der Zöllner, der nimmt dann halt den Fuffi und davon behält er halt irgendwie keine Ahnung, fünf Euro oder so. Und dann gehen noch fünf Euro an seine Kollegen, die auf derselben Schicht sind und der Rest wird dann weiter nach oben verteilt und geht dann wie in so einem umgekehrten Schneeballsystem eben dann bis zum Innenminister oder Zollchef oder so wieder zurück, der eben dann die, ja, bei dem dann alles zusammenläuft.
Ich finde das immer wieder spannend. Also ich bin da in Amerika, kann ich aber sagen, was es da für Parallelen gibt mit dem, mit der normalen Wirtschaft. Denn in Amerika ist es ja so, wenn man im Restaurant isst, dass erwartet wird, dass man 15 bis 25 Prozent Trinkgeld hinterlässt.
25 Prozent.
Das ist immer mehr geworden über die Jahre. Also man sagt so 15 Prozent ist das Minimum, 25 Prozent ja und 25, wenn du so zufrieden warst. Je nachdem wie hervorragend die dich bedient haben. Aber wie viel das jetzt ist, finde ich ja nebensächlich an der Stelle, sondern der Punkt ist, dass es genauso begründet wird, dass die eigentlich nichts verdienen, die armen Leute, die da die kennen. Und jetzt gab es hier gerade einen sehr kontroversen Vorschlag von irgendwelchen Randgruppen, Republikanern, die meinten, man müsste doch den Mindestlohn absenken für die Berufe, wo es Trinkgeld gibt. Mit der Begründung, dass sie ja Trinkgeld kriegen und da muss man auch nicht so viel zahlen. Also diese, wenn man sich einmal auch so was einlässt, dann ist es auch selbst verstärkend. Deswegen, egal aus welchen Gründen, wenn es diese Art von Korruption oder Trinkgeld-Sachen gibt, das geht eigentlich immer nach hinten los, gefolgswirtschaftlich gesehen. Dieser Entwurf, der hat sich gerade nicht sonderlich irgendwie weiterentwickelt, aber er hat es immerhin in die Daily-Show geschafft, das ist schon mal ein Ritterschlag für besonders bekloppte Gesetze.
Das finde ich ja durchaus interessant, dass es genau diese Parallele gibt. Woanders ist es ja eben auch so, wenn man sonst sich nach Afrika oder so guckt oder gerade nordafrikanische Länder, da ist es ja auch in Osteuropa oder noch weiter östlich, da ist es ja eben so, dass der Bestandteil an Korruption im Alltag ja primär damit zu tun hat, dass die Bürokratie ansonsten nicht funktioniert. Also dass sie halt sehr arbitrier ist, dass es halt keine Möglichkeiten gibt, den Beamten dazu zu zwingen, irgendwas zu tun oder irgendwie mal zu handeln.
Die muss ja auch so sein, sonst kannst du ja kein Trinkgeld verlangen oder Schmiergeld.
Ja, aber das ist ja genau das System dahinter. Also wenn man sich Deutschland anguckt, so irgendwie so scheiße unsere Bürokratie hier ist, kann man doch sagen, dass sie im Wesentlichen einigermaßen gut funktioniert. Also gerade mindestens im Vergleich zu einem anderen. Und dass es zumindest irgendwie so was Ähnliches wie, naja, so einen gewissen Ablauf gibt und so eine Regeln gibt, denen dann halt gefolgt wird und die dann halt so ein gewisses Maß an Verlässlichkeit aufweisen. Und natürlich gibt es halt auch hier Korruption. Halt irgendwie gerade in Bereichen, wo es halt große Ermessensspielräume gibt, dass es sich zum Beispiel irgendwie...
Bauwesen.
Baugenehmigungen sind halt so der Klassiker. Und insbesondere überall, wo halt viel Geld dabei ist, da wird ja natürlich immer gerne mitgenommen, so wie es halt irgendwie geht. Aber interessanterweise ist das Risiko, da erwischt zu werden, eben nicht null. Es ist halt schon so, dass es dann gewisse Ermittlungstätigkeiten gibt und eben beide Seiten sich da ins Risiko begeben. Also sowohl der Bestechende als auch der Bestochene. Und das ist ja eben auch das Interessante, was jetzt bei dieser Wulff-Geschichte hochkam, dass, also wie empört diese Beamten waren, also wie krass die das fanden und zwar zu Recht, dass der Wulff es sich rausnimmt, halt da quasi über dem Gesetz zu stehen und die sich halt rechtfertigen müssen, wenn sie eine Schachtel Pralinen für 20 Euro annehmen. Und zwar so richtig rechtfertigen müssen.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass der Wulff, wenn er gesagt hätte, ach das tut mir leid, war nicht so gemeint, dann wäre gut gewesen. Aber dass der sich hingestellt hat und so getan hat, als sei das überhaupt kein Ding. Ja, der hat ja nicht mal geheuchelt, dass es ihm leid tut. Oder überhaupt irgendein Schuldverständnis auch nur simuliert. Ich glaube, das hat die Beamten geärgert. Das geht ja nicht um die Pralinen da, sondern es geht halt darum, dass wir unsere Beamten dran salieren. Es gab da einige Zeitungsberichte, wie zum Beispiel Polizisten nicht mal irgendwie ein Lolli annehmen dürfen. Also es gibt irgendwie eine Barrettellgrenze von, weiß ich nicht, fünf Euro oder so.
Zehn, glaube ich.
Oder zehn. Aber ein Blumenstrauß ist schon zu viel. Ja, wenn irgendwie ein Polizist einer Oma über die Straße hilft, dann darf die keinem Blumenstrauß zurückgehen oder irgendwie umgekehrt. Das würde ich noch nicht als Korruption sehen. Und die meisten Bevölkerung sieht es auch nicht als Korruption, sondern so irgendwie mal eine Schachtel Pralinen schicken. Wenn einem jemand wirklich geholfen hat, ist doch okay. Aber bei dem Wulff war ja auch nicht das Ding, dass er halt eine große Sache gemacht hat oder zwei große, sondern es war ja so ein Blubbersumpf. Ja, man sah einfach mal, man will es ja nicht sehen normalerweise. Man sieht es ja auch normalerweise nicht. Aber das war so eine derartige Kultur an Korruption, dass es da wochenlang blubberte. Am Ende waren es irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, sieben oder neun Wochen, wo einfach ständig irgendwelche Scheiße hochblubberte. Von wegen ja, und dann hat er hier eine Gefälligkeit und da eine Gefälligkeit. Und da sah man eben, dass das System immanent ist. Das ist nicht so eine Sache, die irgendwie zwei, drei faule Eier machen, sondern das gehört ja immer, gehören ja mal zwei Seiten dazu. Und wenn es so viele Leute gibt, die bereit sind, Gefährlichkeiten zu geben, dann kann mir keiner erzählen, dass es nur der Wulff ist. Ja, sondern das ist ein breites Problem. Das sieht man nun normalerweise nicht.
Ja, ich denke mal, das hat auch eine Menge damit zu tun, dass es eben Bereiche der Gesellschaft gibt, die sind halt noch nicht so lange reich. Also bei denen gibt es halt eben noch keine Kultur der Korruption. Und da gehört zum einen halt Wulff auf der einen Seite, also auf der Empfängerseite dazu, der halt ja wirklich in die, sozusagen, Definition von Neureich fällt, aber eben auch die Leute, die ihn da bestochen haben. Es waren halt nicht so die, die Alten, die halt schon irgendwie, sagen wir mal, eine institutionelle Erfahrung über mehrere Generationen haben, wie man Politik besticht, sondern halt so irgendwelche Filmfunks, Fruzis, die halt irgendwie, na ja, es ist gerade eben mal so ein bisschen zu Wohlstand und Geld gekommen sind und jetzt irgendwie erstmal lernen müssen, wie man damit so umgeht. Und ich glaube, dieser, dieser Kulturclash zwischen diesen, also diese Kulturkonfusion zwischen diesen beiden Klassen hat dann eben dazu geführt, dass sie denn ja sich, also außerhalb des gesellschaftlichen Konsens, was eben noch so akzeptabel ist, bewegen. Und wenn wir uns, wenn wir uns so angucken, so wie, wie zum Beispiel der Leuner-Skandal lief oder halt irgendwie die Flick-Geschichten oder so die anderen großen Korruptionsskandaler Republik, da war es ja immer so, dass sie sich bemüht haben, es möglichst komplex zu machen. Also dass halt die Komplexität des Skandals so hochgeschraubt wurde mit also vielen Beteiligten und Unterkonten und Schattenkonten und irgendwie über Luxemburg und den und her, dass es eigentlich schwierig war, da eine richtige Story draus zu machen. Also bis hin zu den jüdischen Vermächtnissen und ähnlichen Geschichten, die tatsächlich heute im Amt befindliche Minister nicht ganz unbeteiligt waren dabei. Und trotzdem gehört es jetzt zwar zur Geschichte der Republik so ein bisschen dazu, aber es ist halt so eine schattige, unfassbare Geschichte. Während das bei Wulff war es halt so, naja eben so Kleinscheiß, ja irgendwie so Hotels, Hotelaufenthalte und irgendwie Autos und irgendwie sowas. Und deshalb macht die Sache so fassbar und so plastisch, weswegen sich dann eben auch so viele Leute drüber aufgeregt haben, so die eben ja eben nicht mal einen Blumenstrauß annehmen dürfen.
Also ich hatte auch ein bisschen den Eindruck, es gibt da noch so den Versuch, bei S21 so ein Too-Big-Too-Fail zu probieren, als Gegenentwurf zu dem komplexen Mesh, was man überhaupt nicht mehr darstellen kann in einem normalen Zeitungsartikel, weil es zu komplex ist. Bei S21 gab es ja wohl auch relativ klare Indizien dafür, dass da von links nach rechts und zurück bestochen wurde. Aber da war der Ansatz eben, naja, aber es geht hier um so viele Milliarden. Wenn wir anfangen, die Firmen anzugreifen, dann sitzen wir selber alle im Knast. Also da ging es weniger darum, das komplex zu machen, sondern möglichst viele Leute zu beteiligen, was ja auch eine valide Strategie ist. Weil wer macht den Ankläger, wenn jeder ein paar Mark genommen hat?
Also du meinst noch die Motto einfach, das gesamte Environment bestechen?
Ja, das war ja die Innovation von dem Flick. Das können wir vielleicht noch mal kurz ein bisschen erklären. Der hat Carpetbombing betrieben im Grunde. Der hat sich damit sein Flugzeug über dem Regierungsviertel navigiert und hat einfach die Geldsäcke abgeworfen. Das war so scheißegal, wen er traf, Hauptsache, wie möglichst breit. Der Maschmeyer, wenn man so den Spiegelberichten glauben darf, ist ja wohl ähnlich gelagert gewesen. Der hat ja auch einfach mal wahllos in die Landespolitiker investiert. Also so mal in jeden. Funktioniert offensichtlich, ne?
Ja, das ist eben genau dieses Konzept der Landschaftspflege. Also dass man eben den, was damals im Bezug zum Flick-Skandals kam, wo es halt, also da gab es ja, wie hieß der Mann von Brauchitsch, hieß der genau, der da beteiligt war. Und das Konzept war eben, dass sie eben nicht eine Partei nur bestochen haben oder sich politisch auf eine Serte geschlagen haben, sondern eben einfach alle, die in diesem Politikspiel irgendeine Art von Relevanz haben, sich ihnen ja gefügig bzw. gefällig gemacht haben. Und wenn man sich so die Preise anguckt, für was zum Beispiel halt so diese Leunerskandale, ähnliche Dinge über den Tisch gehen, dann ist das halt für so ein Milliardenkonzern auch wirklich irgendwie Kinkerlitzchen. Also das ist halt irgendwie keine großartige Investition im finanziellen Sinne, sondern das einzige Risiko, was man hat, ist, dass es halt irgendwann rauskommt.
Ja, und selbst dann gibt es ja, also fällt mir jetzt spontan keinen Fall ein, wo irgendeine Firma deswegen runtergefahren wurde. Weil sie erwischt wurde, Politiker breitflächig zu schmieren, sondern das ist dann halt ein bisschen in der Presse und dann sagen alle, oh, das war aber ein schlauer Geschäftsmann. Ich meine, man konnte das ja sogar mal absetzen, steuerlich in Deutschland.
Ja, das haben sie irgendwann ja eingestellt. Na gut, ich meine, es gab ja schon Fälle wie zum Beispiel, wo Siemens wegen der Auslandskorruption zur Geschäftsbeschaffung in München großflächig vor Gericht stand bzw. gegen die ermittelt wurde und sie dann da auch relativ signifikante Summen irgendwie zurückstellen müssen, um halt diese Strafen irgendwann zahlen zu müssen. Aber man zahlt halt eben nur das, wofür man erwischt wurde. Und es gibt halt irgendwie keine Kultur, die sagt irgendwie, okay, ne, macht man halt nicht, wenn das Risiko erwischt zu werden, gering ist, dann passiert das halt eben doch so. Und da gibt es halt dann ja die kreativsten Methoden. Also gerade so im Bereich von großen öffentlichen Aufträgen oder auch anderweitiger Korruption, zum Beispiel bei kreditvergaben, da ist es dann häufiger so, dass eben nicht der Amtsträger oder der Entscheider selber bestochen wird, sondern die meisten großen Firmen und Konzerne haben halt Kunstsammlungen. Also halt so, wo sie halt irgendwie Kunst kaufen und sammeln. Aber dann begibt es sich eben, dass häufiger die Lebensgefährten oder Gefährtinnen von eben diesen Entscheidungsträgern eben Künstler sind, die dann halt teilweise nicht so unbedingt tolle Kunst produzieren, die aber dann doch gerne gekauft wird von diesen Unternehmen, die dann damit eben diesen Entscheidungsträger indirekt bestechen. Und da wurde mir erklärt, so einen ganzen Zweig von so Galeristen, die sich darauf spezialisiert haben, solche Dinge durchzuziehen, indem sie halt den Wert von solcher, ja, sagen wir mal, Entscheidungsträger nahen Kunst nach oben bringen, indem sie halt irgendwie viel teuer Geld anpreisen, damit die Unternehmen dann auch problemlos rechtfertigen können, warum sie diese dann gekauft haben.
Aber wir waren bei der Revolving Door.
Genau, wir wollten ja mal ein bisschen erklären, wie es zu dieser Revolving Door kam. Und einer der Gründe ist eben, dass es, dass es eben einen durchaus einen Ermittlungsdruck gibt und jemand, der halt möglicherweise noch Reste von Gewissen hat, eben sich dann doch doof fühlt, wenn er dann halt den direkten oder indirekten Bargeldkoffer nimmt. Und deswegen ist diese Revolving Door entstanden, die halt diese ganze Sache indirekt macht und auf die Ebene eines Versprechens hebt.
Da gibt es auch nochmal Unterschiede zwischen den einzelnen Ländern. Das europäische Modell ist eher, dass man halt, nachdem man in der Politik den Firmen geholfen hat, bei den Firmen anfängt. Der letzte Fall, der mir spontan einfällt, ist Roland Koch, aber das kommt alle naselang vor. In Amerika geht das Modell noch ein Stück weiter. Da geht es nämlich in beide Richtungen. Da ist es also so, dass nicht nur der Minister nach seiner Arbeit bei Monsanto anfängt, der Agrarminister, sondern dass er auch vorher bei Monsanto gearbeitet hat, und zwar als Lobbyist auch tatsächlich für die. Das heißt, da gibt es also deutlich weniger, die Stink-aber-Schwelle ist deutlich höher in Amerika als bei uns. Besonders krass ist das Finanzministerium und die Notenbank der USA, die fast vollständig aus Bankern von Goldman Sachs und Co. besteht, und sogar der Minister ist ein Ex-G Goldman Sachs Mann. Und so ist das eben auch eine Sache, die sich dann selbst trägt. Wenn man einmal anfängt, das zur Tradition werden zu lassen, dann die Banker kennen auch nichts und spenden an beide Parteien, die hier zur Wahl stehen, die Demokraten und die Republikaner, in ungefähr gleichgroßen Teilen. Das ist sogar für die, die an der Macht sind jeweils ein bisschen mehr. Und dementsprechend fühlt sich Obama dann natürlich auch verpflichtet, wenn er an der Macht ist, wieder Goldman Sachs Leute zu seinen Beratern zu machen. Und so gibt es eben diese Drehtür, wo ständig irgendwelche Leute reinlaufen und die kommen dann auf der anderen Seite raus und sind aber in einem anderen Amt. Und die Amerikaner finden da auch wenig bei. Wenn das mal jemand anspricht, dann gibt es eben so irgendwelche Pundits, nennt man die hier, das sind so Presse-Spezialexperten, die dann da gefragt werden und die sagen, ja, wir haben halt jemanden gebraucht, der sich auskennt mit Geld und haben einen Denker genommen.
Sie wissen halt ja, worum es geht. Das ist ja die Begründung immer dafür, wieso man halt Leute aus der Industrie oder aus den Banken oder so holt, ist ja, dass es nicht genug Sachkompetenz in den Häusern selber gibt, also in den Ministerien oder in den Behörden. Und man daher eben Leute nehmen muss, die ja eben aus der Praxis kommen. Und in Deutschland gibt es ja diese spezielle Variante davon. Das sind halt eben die Leihbeamten. Also Leute, die eigentlich noch weiter von Siemens oder irgendwelchen anderen großen Firmen angestellt sind und aber in den Ministerien arbeiten. Das heißt also, die halt quasi von den Firmen ausgeliehen werden für eine bestimmte Zeit und dann halt in den Ministerien halt zum Beispiel Gesetzesvorlagen und Verordnungen schreiben, die wiederum ihren Arbeitgeber durchaus betreffen können.
Das Schöne an der Sache ist, dass man ganz schön sehen kann, was das für eine fiese Doppelmoral ist. Denn in Amerika fallen diese Revolving Door Lobbyisten immer dadurch auf, dass sie sich dann auch öffentlich als Altruisten darzustellen versuchen. Die geben dann Interviews oder die Presse schreibt geifend, ja guckt euch mal diesen Mann an, der hätte Millionen verdienen können als Banker, aber jetzt macht er hier für für Peanuts den Finanzminister und das ist ein Held. Das macht Deutschland nicht mit. Bei uns wird man weiter von der Industrie bezahlt, während man die Politik korrumpiert und deswegen haben wir diese Private-Public-Partnership. Die ist übrigens eingeführt worden unter Schulab. Das ist eine SPD-Innovation.
Na wie immer bei solchen Sachen, ja. Aber das finde ich interessant, dieses Detail, was du gerade sagtest, dass die es dann immer noch versuchen, so darzustellen, als wenn sie denn als ein großes Opfer bringen, wenn sie sich patriotisch in den Dienst des Vaterlandes stürzen und irgendwie da...
Also das gibt es bei uns auch, dass die Industrie dann immer sagt, nee, also ich stehe hier nicht zur Verfügung, weil da verdient man ja auch nichts. Also das gibt es ja in Talkshows häufiger, das Argument, die armen Politiker verdienen viel zu wenig. Also das geht ja immer in beide Richtungen. Die Politiker benutzen das ja jedes Mal, wenn sie sich eine Diätenerhöhung beschließen. Ach guck mal, die in der Industrie verdienen so viel besser.
Na gut, ich meine, es gibt ja viele andere Gründe, nicht in die Politik gehen zu wollen. Aber Geld ist vielleicht nur nicht unbedingt der wichtigste davon.
Aber nicht das tragende Elemente.
Wird das in Amerika den Leuten abgenommen? Also machen die das so mit? Ist das dann eher so ein zynischer Unterton, wenn darüber berichtet wird, dass jetzt so ein Banker irgendwie für vier Jahre in die Regierung geht und ihm dadurch irgendwie viele Millionen entgehen?
Nee, nee, das ist wie, wenn... Also die Amerikaner haben sowieso so eine, ich will nicht sagen, naive Einstellung, aber die sagen ja auch quasi Leute, die zum Militär gehen, sind Helden. Das würde man ja bei uns auch nie in der öffentlichen Diskussion so bringen. Also die sagen das und meinen das auch gar nicht zynisch. Und ein Großteil der Bevölkerung kauft es denen auch ab, dass man sagt, das ist aber ein Held, der hätte hier in seinen Banken als Banker richtig Kohle machen können. Und der ist jetzt Finanzminister. Und wenn es dann mal einen Bericht gibt, was ja relativ selten ist, aber es gibt also zumindest einen fiesen Reporter namens Matt Tybee, der sich da immer für den Rolling Stone rein durch den Schlamm wühlt. Und der erklärt dann halt in regelmäßigen Abständen, was diese Industrie-Revolving-Doll-Leute gerade wieder für Gesetze gemacht haben. Und da sieht man dann eben die einzige Investmentbank, die das Armageddon überlebt hat, ist Goldman Sachs. Und die haben zufälligerweise gerade den Minister gestellt. Also das ist schon vielleicht nicht direkt Geld, was direkt an den Typ fließt, aber das kriegt er mit sich halt als Bonus ausgezahlt, wenn er zurückgeht nach seinem Job zu Goldman Sachs. Natürlich. Aber die Amerikaner sind eher so der Meinung wie, naja, aber das hat er doch schlau eingefädelt. Das ist aber ein schlauer Geschäftsmann. Also das wird hier gar nicht so, wenn jemand erwischt wird, der wirklich eine üble Abzocke gefunden hat, dann wird es gerne mal positiv gewertet auch, weil das hätte ich aber oft je, die hätte ich aber auch gerne bekommen. Das ist also nicht hilfreich. Hier Korruption aufdecken hat eigentlich fast nie irgendwelche Auswirkungen. Wenn man hier einen Politiker aus seinem Amt fegen will, dann muss man eben Untreue in seinem Privatleben vorwerfen. So, gegen Korruption ist hier noch nie irgendeine zurückgezogen.
Also wenn, dann geht es nur mit Sexkandal.
So sieht es aus.
Na super.
Gut, wir wollten auch noch ein bisschen mehr erklären, wie die Politik funktioniert. Wir wollten nicht nur Korruption haben.
Das fließt ja durchaus Hand in Hand. Also eine der wesentlichen Aufgaben von Politik ist ja, neben halt Entscheidungen zu treffen, durchaus auch erklären. Also versuchen, ja Politik zu vermitteln, also zu sagen, warum bestimmte Dinge notwendig sind oder darauf hinzuweisen, dass solche Sachen wichtig sind. Und auch da ist es ja so, dass der gemeine Politiker ist ja häufiger mal auch so von Themen überfordert. Es gibt halt ja durchaus ein paar fähige Sachpolitiker, wo man nicht leugnen will, die möglicherweise auch nicht besonders korrupt sind. Aber die Regel ist halt, ja ein Politiker, der nicht so besonders viel von seinem Fach versteht, sondern irgendwie maximal eine schnelle Auffassungsgabe hat und irgendwie sich guten Namen und Gesichter merken kann und gut Hände schütteln kann. Und der Versuch, eben Sachpolitik zu machen, scheitert ja häufiger eben daran, dass sie halt einfach schwer zu vermitteln ist. Und deswegen wird Politik halt auch immer mehr zu so einem PR-Ding. Also halt einfach irgendwie den ist in der Presse verkaufen können oder es zu labeln mit irgendwas, was irgendwie positiv klingt, ist zu einer Hauptaufgabe von Politik geworden. Und da beschäftigen sich halt auch durchaus größere Teilmengen der Beamten in den Ministerien, dass sie halt irgendwie die Politik ihres Hauses irgendwie toll labeln verkaufen und am besten noch mit irgendwelchen Neusprechworten rechtfertigen müssen.
Das Spannende ist, dass viele von den Erklärungen, die es da gibt, überhaupt nicht überzeugen können, wenn man sich die mal näher anguckt. Also das hat mich jahrelang sehr gestört. Ich komme nachher darauf, warum das so ist, warum das trotzdem reicht. Aber man sieht ganz deutlich, wenn Journalisten sich mit Politikern unterhalten, dass die die mit grotesk schlechten Erklärungen durchkommen lassen. Aber das geht nicht nur zwischen Politiker und Bevölkerung, sondern es geht auch zwischen Lobbyist und Politiker. Also inzwischen ist es so, dass die Politiker eigentlich gar nicht selbst mit den schlechten Ausreden kommen, sondern dass die durchgereicht werden. Da gibt es eben Spezialistenabteilungen, eine große Professionalisierung von schlechten Ausreden. Früher musste man sich die noch selber ausdenken.
Jetzt gibt es dann halt eben Full-Service Packages. Also die Entscheidung oder die Richtung, die man da haben will, ist dann gleich kombiniert mit der entsprechenden PR dazu. Also irgendwelchen Studien. Und wenn es geht, sogar noch irgendwelche Neusprechworten, die dann halt irgendwie, was ist das, sowas wie Riester-Rente. Das ist ein ganz grandioses Beispiel dafür. Also es klingt ja erst mal positiv. Also nach mehr Rente und so. Und Herr Riester sah auch erst mal ganz honorisch aus, bevor rauskommt, was er so in seiner Freizeit gemacht hat. Und die Idee dabei war ja, am Ende dafür zu sorgen, dass irgendwie den ganzen Finanzabzockern, irgendwie diesen Finanz, wie heißen die, Optimierer, die dann irgendwie solche Dinge verkaufen, denen halt große Mengen Geld zuzuschustern und begründet wurden.
Der Riester kam ja auch aus diesem Hannoveranersumpf, das kann man nicht, das ist vielleicht noch mal mal. Und der leitende Finanzoptimierer Deutschlands ist die AWD, deren Chef der Maschmeyer ist, der jetzt im Wulff-Skandal, also das ist schon alles dieselbe Mischpoke, die man da trifft.
Und der wiederum eben ein guter Freund von Schröder ist, der eben dafür gesorgt hat, dass diese Riester dann nochmal durchgeht. Genau.
Also das ist schon alles eine Handwisch die andere.
Und das ist halt eben ein Niveau von Korruption, was eben auch üblich geworden ist, dass man eben nicht mehr eine konkrete Sache möchte, wie zum Beispiel diese FDP-Steuererleichterung für Hoteliers, die dann auch nach hinten losgegangen ist, weil man die Frühstücke plötzlich extra verbuchen musste, sondern dass man das gesamte Umfeld, also die gesamte Struktur der Gesellschaft an dieser Ecke so verändert, dass der eigene Konzern optimal positioniert ist, um davon zu profitieren. Und dazu gehören halt eben diese Finanzoptimierer und sonstigen Drückerkolonnen, die davon massiv profitiert haben, dass plötzlich eben mit der entsprechenden Begründung Demografie und man muss ja da und irgendwie die Rente wird nicht reichen und so, was ja möglicherweise objektiv sogar der Fall ist. Aber wie das Gesetz dann hinterher designed wurde, war es am Ende der große Bonusregen für diese ganzen schmierigen Finanzvertreter, die losgegangen sind und den Leuten irgendwie diese Renten verkauft haben, die jetzt wie sich hinterher herausstellt, sofern sie irgendwie dann auf irgendwelche Staatsanleihen oder Aktien basiert waren, halt eben wieder für die Füße sind.
Naja, die werden auf Hartz IV angerechnet. Das war eine große Umverteilung des Geldes von den staatlichen Versicherungen zu den privaten und dementsprechend werden die wahrscheinlich auch im Hintergrund finanziert haben. Also diese Optimierer, ob die jetzt eher Mit-Esser sind oder das eigentliche Ziel ist ja auch egal.
Nee, das kann man schon sagen, dass sie das Ziel waren. Also wenn du dir anguckst, was die getan haben in der Zeit, da gibt es auch so eine grandiose Doku geradezu AWD, wo sie halt eben auch zeigen, wie viel von diesen Renten und Lebensversicherungen, die da eben steuerlich gefördert wurden, dann tatsächlich erstmal an Provisionen hängen bleibt bei denen. Und wie wenig, also erst nach vielen Jahren, ich glaube nach vier Jahren oder so, fängt man tatsächlich an, da effektiv einzuzahlen. Vorher zahlt man erstmal die Provisionen von diesem Vermittler ab. So bei den besonders krassen Konstrukten. Das ist halt eine Sache so, dass die nicht explizit abgefangen wurden. Und es da eben von der Gesetzgeberseite keine Verhinderungstaktik gab, zu sagen, dass Provisionen auf maximal so und so viel begrenzt werden dürfen, zeigt eben ganz klar durch Auslassen von solchen Regeln, von wem die intendiert waren und was da das eigentliche Ziel dabei war. Die Versicherungswirtschaft hat eben genau von dieser Sache massiv profitiert. Also plötzlich sind da die Einlagen sowohl in Riesler Renten als auch in Nehmversicherungen brutal gestiegen. So und wenn wir uns jetzt angucken, die Lebensversicherungen, so die, also viele von denen haben ja irgendwie in Staatsanleihen investiert, auch in europäische Staatsanleihen. Die werden in wenigen Jahren überhaupt gar nichts mehr wert sein. Also die, die Garantieverzinsungen fallen und fallen. Und am Ende ist das halt irgendwie eine große Verarsche gewesen.
Na der Brüller ist ja, dass das hintenrum dann wieder gegen uns verwendet wird. Ja, wenn, wenn jetzt irgendwelche wackeligen Staatsanleihen oder Banken gerettet werden sollen, dann ist ja immer das Argument, naja, das sind ja eure Rentenversicherung. Ja, und wenn man mal nachguckt, sind das die Versicherungen, die ihnen irgendwas auszahlen würden, wenn sie nämlich unter dem Hartz-IV-Satz auszahlen würden und angerechnet werden. Also das ist ja der große Lacher bei der Christa-Renten. Aber gut, die Sache, die wir eigentlich beobachten wollten, ist, dass die Politik sich entwickelt hat von wir wollen die Leute überzeugen zu wir wollen die Leute überreden. Also früher, früher haben die Politiker noch Argumente gebracht, wo man den Eindruck hatte, da geht es tatsächlich darum, dass sie mir inhaltlich erklären wollen, was sie da tun und warum sie es tun. Und heute sind das alles so PR-Blasen. Und deswegen muss man auch die Politik insgesamt so ein bisschen als PR-Blase betrachten und man muss sich informieren, wie eigentlich PR funktioniert und muss sich damit auseinandersetzen. Und wir wollen mit dieser Sendung ein bisschen versuchen, unseren Teil beizutragen. Die erste Beobachtung ist, dass man immer irgendwelche positiven Handlungen zu basteln versucht, wenn man das macht.
Also positive Adäquive assoziiert.
Genau, die klassische PR-Technik, dass man, wenn man schon seinen Brandnamen nicht irgendwie neusprecherisch basteln kann, dann überlegt man sich irgendwelche, so wenn man das Agenda 2010 zum Beispiel ist. Agenda klingt ja, als wenn da jemand nachgedacht hat und als wenn es einen Plan gibt, aber das war ja das Gegenteil. Und so ist das eben auch mit anderen Geldausgabesachen der Regierung. Da geht es dann um humanitäre Aktionen, um Hilfe, Unterstützung. Ja, der größte Neusprechkracher an der Stelle ist in meiner Ansicht nach immer die Militärhilfe. Wenn man hört, die Amerikaner haben den Griechen 400 Panzer verkauft und dann läuft das unter Militärhilfe bei den Amerikanern.
Das ist halt Hilfe, ne? Also musst du da ganz offenbar jemand aus ganz schwerer Nothilfe, also dem fehlt ein ganz dringender Panzer.
Ja, wer kann was gegen Hilfe sagen? Und wenn unser Entwicklungshilfeminister Nibel seine Bundeswehr da los schickt, das ist ja auch überhaupt unter Hilfe. Überhaupt Entwicklungshilfe muss man sich mal näher ansehen. Denn das hat ja wenig mit Hilfe und wenig mit Entwicklung zu tun. Sondern eigentlich ist das eine Idee, wie man seine eigene Industrie subventionieren kann. Also die Idee ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, Griechenland als Opferland, dass wir denen Kredit geben und damit kaufen die dann Infrastruktur, wie zum Beispiel ein Kraftwerk ein. Und das kaufen sie wahrscheinlich bei uns ein. Sie sind Marktführer, sag ich mal. Und damit haben wir quasi das Geld, also das Geld kommt ja von uns, das haben wir den Griechenland geliehen, die kaufen damit bei uns ein. Das hat sich im Laufe der Jahre entwickelt. Inzwischen ist es so, dass wir Griechenland das Geld gar nicht mehr geben, sondern dass es auf dem Treuhänderkonto liegt, damit die auch gar nicht auf die Idee kommen, damit woanders einzukaufen.
Ja, nicht, dass sie sich das irgendwie, keine Ahnung, dafür...
Dass sie damit sinnvolle Dinge tun.
Oder gar irgendwie sinnvolle Dinge tun, ja, so können wir das sagen.
Ja, das geht gar nicht. Inzwischen läuft das über irgendwelche Treuhänderkonto, das heißt, wir geben denen quasi ziemlich direkt unsere Produkte. Das heißt, unsere Regierung zahlt unsere Industrie dafür, Produkte zu bauen, die dann ins Ausland geben und auf dem Papier schuldet uns Griechenland dann Geld. Aber der eigentliche Nutzeffekt ist ja nicht das Geld, was die uns schulden, sondern dass unsere Industrie was zu tun hatte. So haben wir nämlich die Rezession überlebt. Deutschland hat einfach weiter produziert mit Entwicklungshilfe. Es gab da jetzt vor ein paar Tagen diese Meldungen, die ich immer noch am Verdauen bin, dass sie in den Büchern der Bundesbank 500 Milliarden an Forderungen an die üblichen verdächtigen Länder gefunden haben, so Griechenland, Italien, Spanien. Und 500 Milliarden ist also mal ein Wort. Ja, das ist kein Trivialbetrag. Und damit hat die Bundesbank im Wesentlichen den Exportüberschuss von Deutschland gekauft und ins Ausland gegeben und auf dem Papier schuldet uns jetzt natürlich das Ausland das Geld.
Genau, ich meine, wir dachten ja bisher immer, dass irgendwie Deutschland da irgendwie anders wäre als zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal, China oder so. Aber de facto haben wir genau dasselbe gemacht wie China.
Genau, China macht es mit den USA und mit der Europäischen Union, aber hauptsächlich eben mit den USA, dass China im Grunde einen riesigen Exportüberschuss erwirtschaftet und das Geld, was sie da einnehmen, direkt wieder den Amerikanern leihen. Und die kaufen damit gleich wieder in China ein. Und so hat sich da ein unglaubliches Defizit aufgebaut, im Kreis viel mehr als tatsächlich Geld in Bewegung war, weil das ja in meinem Kreis fließt. Und genau so was macht Deutschland eben auch. Aber die zentrale Einsicht an der Stelle ist eben, dass wir ein Konjunkturprogramm gefahren haben. So nennt man das nämlich, wenn die Regierung losläuft und die Industrie fördert. Wenn wir Schulden machen, bzw. in dem Fall drücken wir die Schulden dann in Griechenland auf, aber im Wesentlichen wird hier mit Schulden in der Rezession die Industrie am Laufen gehalten. Das haben wir gemacht. Und was jetzt gerade läuft mit Griechenland, ist, wir denen sagen, ihr müsst was machen wie wir, was ja richtig ist, aber dann, ihr müsst Sparmaßnahmen machen, was ja bei uns so irgendwie der Mythos gerade ist, dass Deutschland die Rezession mit Sparmaßnahmen überlebt hat. Das ist ja kompletter Blödsinn. Wir haben die Rezession überwunden, weil wir hier so eine fette Industrieförderung gefahren haben. Und das ist eben eine große PR-Lüge gerade.
Naja, nicht nur irgendwie über diesen Aufkauf unseres Exportüberschusses durch die Bundesbank, sondern eben auch darüber, dass Moniturprogramme, also eben Direktsteuergelder, dafür verwendet wurden, um die Industrie aufzupäppeln. Und nur deswegen hat Deutschland die Rezessionen einigermaßen überstanden mit einem relativ geringen Anstieg der Arbeitslosigkeit. Und das am Ende, was wir da gerade tun, ist dieses Weltbankprogramm fahren. Und wir sind über dieses IWF-Programm, das sollten wir vielleicht noch mal kurz erläutern.
Ja, da kommen wir noch in Ruhe drauf. Aber ein Punkt, den wir an dieser Stelle machen wollen, ist, dass die meisten von diesen Ausdrücken, die man hört, um Sachen zu begründen, eigentlich das exakte Gegenteil dessen sind, was tatsächlich passiert. Und wenn man dann die Rhetorik und die tatsächlichen Taten vergleicht, dann hört man Hilfe und am Ende sind Waffen geliefert worden. Oder man hört, die Vatikanenbank investiert am Ende in Kondomfabriken. Das war jetzt so ein Skandal, ich glaube, vor zwei Jahren oder so ist das rausgekommen. Die tun eigentlich häufig das Gegenteil dessen, was sie gesagt haben. Wir haben so ein ähnliches Ding ja auch mit Krisengebieten. Wir haben eine offizielle Policy, dass wir keine Waffen in Krisenrebiete liefern. Aber das hat uns die davon abgehalten, im Nahen Osten Israel U-Boote zu schenken. Die Amerikaner machen das noch cooler. Die sagen, sie machen Stabilisierung und liefern dann auch an Ägypten großflächig Militär.
Oder wie wir jetzt irgendwie in Deutschland, wie plant Panzer, an Saudi-Arabien zu liefern? Das ist halt auch eine Stabilisierungsmaßnahme.
Und Stabilisierung ist natürlich auch ein krasses Neusprech an der Stelle. Das machen wir nicht, um da irgendwas zu stabilisieren, sondern damit unsere Exporte hochgehen.
Nein, nicht nur. Ich meine, bei Israel ist es halt eben so, dass der...
Und da ist es tatsächlich klar.
Die Idee dahinter ist halt schon, also muss man vielleicht mal nochmal wieder erläutern, weil es wird ja gerade wieder akut, warum Deutschland an Israel atomwaffenfähige U-Boote liefert. Also diese U-Boote ist die sogenannte Dolphin-Klasse, ist so das Beste, was irgendwie in Deutschland halt irgendwie so derzeit an U-Booten gebaut wird. Und die haben, sind konventionelle U-Boote, die einen Antrieb haben, der auf Wasserstoff beruht. Also wenn sie halt getaucht fahren, dann fahren die halt mit Brennstoffzellen und sind damit quasi kaum zu Orten, weil sie so leise sind. Und die haben Waffenschächte für Torpedos, in die israelische unter Wasser startbare Marschleckörper reinpassen. Und diese Marschleckörper sind auch atomar bestückbar. Also es ist halt so ein Spiel, wo es darum geht, wie dick ist denn dieses Torpedorohr? Da gibt es halt eine spezielle Größe, die halt eigentlich genau für dieses israelischen Marschleckkörper da ist. Und die Israelis haben ja Atomwaffen und diese Atomwaffendoktrine ist ja eine der des Nicht-Zugebens. Also Israel sagt nicht, dass sie Atomwaffen haben. Alle anderen wissen, dass sie Atomwaffen haben. Und Israel ist ja ein ziemlich kleines Land. Das heißt also, wenn die tatsächlich jemals in einen nuklearen Konflikt verwickelt werden sollten, zum Beispiel mit dem Iran, wie sie jetzt ja gerade behaupten, dann haben sie eigentlich quasi keine Chance, weil das Land halt so klein ist. Heißt es, dass also jemand, der nuklearen Erstschlag gegen Israel führen würde, würde dieses Land quasi komplett vernichten und also auch dessen Möglichkeit, zurückzuschlagen, komplett vernichten. Und deswegen wollten Israelis halt schon sehr lange U-Boote haben, mit denen sie eine so genannte Zweitschlagkapazität aufbauen können. Also eine Möglichkeit, Atomwaffen zu starten, von unter Wasser, von U-Booten, die quasi nicht geortet werden können, sodass also jeder, der Israel mit Atomwaffen angreift, nicht in der Lage ist, vorherzusehen, ob Israel jetzt zurückschlagen kann, weil man weiß halt nicht, wo die U-Booten sind. Und so für die ersten ein, zwei, drei U-Booten war das ja möglicherweise noch durchaus eine argumentierbare Überlegung, wieso Deutschland halt diese U-Booten geliefert hat, wenn auch nicht zwingend eine stabilitätsfördernde. Aber mittlerweile sind es gleich wieder sechs oder sieben U-Booten, die die bekommen haben. Und dann fängt es sich schon an, so ein bisschen die Frage der Verhältnismäßigkeit dabei zu stellen.
Ja, was man auch bei diesen Lobbyismus-Geschichten verstehen muss und bei Korruption ist das Korruption ja die, die nicht völlig umdreht, was derjenige tut, sondern nur ein bisschen umlenkt. Also man kann ja niemanden bestechen, damit der dann Selbstmord begeht, sondern der tut nur Sachen, die eh im Rahmen gewesen wären, aber die halt moralisch, ethisch eine Grenze überschreiten. Man muss also nur noch so einen Abstand überspringen mit der Korruption. Man muss einen Impuls setzen, aber man muss nicht komplett denjenigen fernsteuern.
Zumindest in der Regel. Es gibt halt schon durchaus auch Fälle, wo die Korruption halt irgendwie in eine komplette Änderung der Meinung des betreffenden Politikers erkauft wurde.
Ja, aber nur wenn der Politiker dadurch nicht existenziell bedroht ist. Also das ist nichts, was der... Nein, das hat vielleicht seine Meinsfreiheit. Ja, okay.
Er kann doch irgendwie sein Gewissen abstimmen. Herrgott, wo kämen wir denn dahin? Wenn Politiker nicht ihrem Gewissen folgen können und das Gewissen... Na gut, ich meine, man weiß nicht, wem das Gewissen so folgt. Das kann durchaus auch der Brieftasche nach sein. Oder der Pensionsversorgung. Ich meine, muss man ja auch mal sehen, dass das einer der wesentlichen Gründe, warum Leute in Deutschland noch in die Politik gehen, ist eben die Pensionssicherheit.
Ja, das ist ja auch nachvollziehbar. Das wird ja auch weggekürzt für den Nicht-Politiker. Aber ich wollte das ein bisschen illustrieren, ein Beispiel von einer Sache, die ich jetzt gerade in einem Buch gelesen habe. Das Buch heißt Vultures Picnic und ist von Greg Pallas. Das ist ein amerikanischer investigativer Journalist. Und er hat sich mal so Firmen rausgesucht, die er Vultures nennt. Das sind Geier. Also das funktioniert wie folgt.
Arsgeier, um genau zu sehen.
Arsgeier, genau. Das funktioniert wie folgt. So ein Geier sucht sich wertlose Staatsschulden von einem afrikanischen Pleite-Land aus. Und die sind wertlos, weil das Land nicht zahlen kann. Und deswegen werden die unter Wert verkauft. Das ist jetzt wie mit Griechenland. Die Staatsanleihen haben dann halt so den Verlustausfall schon eingepreist und dann kriegt man die für, sagen wir, fünf Cent pro Dollar einen Wert. Weil völlig klar ist, dass man nie wieder an das Geld rankommen wird. So, jetzt geht dieser Geier los, geht zu einem Gericht und lässt die Assets von diesem Pleite-Land einfrieren. Nun ist das Land ja pleite und hat deswegen keine Assets. Aber was diese Waltscher oder diese Geier eben erkämpft haben, ist, dass das Gericht dann die Entwicklungshilfe an das Land einfrieren kann. Das würden normale Länder und Firmen natürlich nicht tun. Weil wenn jetzt irgendwie Deutschland anfängt und Entwicklungshilfe für, was weiß ich, Burkina Faso einzufrieren, das ist ja ein PR-Albtraum. Das macht man also über eine Waltscher-Firma, so ein Geier, der halt speziell dafür gegründet wird und dem seine PR am Arsch vorbeigeht. Und der hat jetzt einen Hebel gegen das Land und geht damit zu dem Diktator von diesem Pleite-Land und sagt, hier lieber Diktator, ich habe hier einen Titel gegen dich über, was weiß ich, eine Milliarde. Oder es ist ja letztendlich egal, wie viel das ist. Hör mal, ich gebe dir hier 50 Millionen, wenn du als Land die Milliarde zurückzahlst. So, und jetzt geht dieser Diktator los und leiht sich von woanders Geld, ja, zum Beispiel von der Weltbank, auf die wir gleich noch kommen werden, und zahlt mit diesem geliehenem Geld den Geyer zurück. Und der Geyer zahlt dann 50 Millionen an die Lieblingswohltätigkeitsorganisation von dem Diktator, die er wahrscheinlich selber gegründet hat, also eine Korruption. Und der wichtige Punkt an der Stelle ist, dass diese Korruption häufig zu Ungunsten des Landes stattfindet, aber zu Gunsten des Diktators. So ist es eben immer mit irgendwelchen Politikern. Man kann die nicht dazu bringen mit Korruption, dass sie sich selbst schaden, aber man kann sie dazu bringen, dass sie andere Leute Geld veruntreuen, weil es eine kleinere Schranke ist. So, das ist natürlich PR-technisch ein absoluter Albtraum, wenn man so einen Geier...
Aber da liest man auch nicht so viel drüber, ne?
Und da liest man fast nichts drüber, dass es sie überhaupt gibt, hat dieser Greg Pallast aufgedeckt und der hat ein paar von denen verfolgt und er hat es immerhin geschafft, dass einzelne Juristiktionen angefangen haben. Ich glaube, England debattiert das gerade oder hat es auch schon beschlossen, dass man bei ihnen diese Entwicklungshilfe einfriere Geschichte nicht mehr machen kann. Also das ist natürlich androhlich und das wird nicht ewig funktionieren, aber man sieht schon, welche Art von Leuten das sind, die an Korruption Geld verdienen.
Am Ende ist es ja genau das selbe Spiel wie diese Umschuldungsabkommen. Also die funktionieren ja ganz genauso, dass man sagt, ok, also du hast dich jetzt, also dieses Land hat sich überschuldet und damit ihr weiter Kredite bekommen könnt, müsst ihr irgendwie diese und jene Dinge tun.
Klassische Weltwährungsfonds, Zuständigkeit und Weltbank.
Genau, Weltwährungsfonds und Weltbanken, genau das selbe, was wir jetzt halt mit Griechenland tun. Da sollten wir mal drüber reden.
Ja, also das funktioniert. Da gibt es so eine Literatur drüber inzwischen. Die ist vor allem rausgekommen, weil Josef Stieglitz, der mal bei der Weltbank zuständig war, irgendwann gesagt hat, der hat die Schnauze voll. Das ist ein amerikanischer Wirtschaftsprofessor. Und der hat mal ausgepackt, übrigens auch bei Greg Pellist. Und der hat mal erzählt, wie das so funktioniert. Es gibt aus den 70ern ein Buch aus der Frühzeit von diesen Mechanismen, das heißt Confessions of an Economic Hitman. Das ist sehr empfehlenswert. Da berichtet ein Mann, der das vor Ort als Agent gemacht hat. Und der berichtet, wie das funktioniert. Also man geht in so ein Land rein, sagen wir mal Saudi Arabien, und sieht, die haben viel Öl. Man will jetzt alles Öl ran, man muss ihnen irgendwas anbieten. Und traditionell, was man halt angeboten hat in solchen Fällen, ist, dass man den Infrastruktur hinstellt. Also zum Beispiel Kraftwerk oder man baut Straßen oder man macht Müllabfuhr, war so ein Klassiker in den afrikanischen Ländern. Man erklärt denen, wie man Müllabfuhr macht oder man fließt Wasser, das ist ja auch keine selbstverständlichkeit mehr gewesen. Und diese Art von Infrastruktur bietet man denen an und zwar macht man das auf Pump. Und erwähnt man erwähnt das noch gar nicht. Man sagt also hier halt mal, wir wollen eure Freunde sein. Wir helfen euch jetzt mal hier, wir geben euch diesen großzügigen Kredit. Und damit geben wir euch, damit müsst ihr dann Straßen bauen. Nun hat das Land natürlich die Kompetenz, nicht um Straßen zu bauen.
Also holen sie halt Bechtel oder sowas.
Also holen sie ein Konzern und zwar natürlich von dem Land, was ihm den Kredit gegeben hat, also Bechtel üblicherweise oder sowas wie Halliburton, würde man heute sagen. Also auch alle großen Baufirmen sind da beteiligt. Übrigens die größte Baufirma in Arabien und Afrika ist die Bin Laden Group. Ja, also so läuft das eben. Das heißt, man schwatzt den irgendwelche Infrastruktur auf, ohne die sie bisher gut klargekommen sind. Und am Ende hat man auf dem Papier eben, haben die große Schulden. Und um die abzuzahlen, müssen sie an ihre Bodenschätze ran. Und weil viele von diesen Ländern, als diese Masche angefangen hat, ihre Bodenschätze noch gar nicht richtig genutzt haben, hat man dann eben als Gegenleistung günstige Konzessionen herausgeschlagen und das so gemacht, dass die Ölförderung an ausländische Firmen vergeben wurde. Das haben nicht alle Länder mit sich machen lassen, aber in vielen Ländern ist das so, dass das Öl eben nicht von staatlichen Unternehmen gefördert wird. Also hier in Norwegen hat es zum Beispiel die Stadt Eul, das ist ein Stadis-Unternehmen. Venezuela hat ein Stadis-Unternehmen, die Saudis haben staatliche Unternehmen. Aber der Irak zum Beispiel, der hat das externe Firmen machen lassen. Und da geht natürlich der Profit dann auch an die externen Firmen. Und damit werden dann eben die Zinsen abgezahlt auf die Infrastrukturkredite, die man denen gegeben hat. Und weil jetzt beide Seiten sowohl die Zinsgeber, als auch die Zinsförderer im Ausland sitzen, hat man einen Prima-Hebel, um das Land immer so gerade so an der Schranke zu halten, davon, dass sie also abhängig sind, und kriegt dann auch politische Konzeptionen aus dieser Sache rausgepresst. Das war so das traditionelle Modell. Inzwischen gibt es halt Weltweltbank und Weltwährungsfonds, die haben das professionalisiert.
Also da geht es halt primär darum, wenn so ein Land halt objektiv überschuldet ist, also nicht mehr in der Lage ist, seine Zinsen und seine Tögung zu zahlen.
Was wir ja herbeigeführt haben, das möchte ich noch mal betonen, das haben wir herbeigeführt über das, was ich eben erklärt habe. Haben wir herbeigeführt, dass diese ganzen Länder hoch verschuldet sind mit Infrastruktur, die sie eigentlich gar nicht gebraucht haben.
Ja, nicht nur Infrastruktur. Ich meine, häufiger genug sind es halt auch irgendwie Militärausgaben, also die halt über solche Kredite finanziert werden.
Na ja, und wo haben sie die gekauft? Auch bei uns zum Militärschutz.
Genau, klar. Also es ist ja nicht nur Infrastruktur, die sie nicht brauchen, sondern einfach Hauptkram, den sie nicht brauchen, so allerhand Zeug. Und meine, bei Infrastruktur kann man ja immer noch drüber streiten, ob es vielleicht möglicherweise Sinn macht oder nicht, aber irgendwie bei vielen Sachen eben gibt es diese Fragen halt nicht, wie zum Beispiel halt irgendwie überbohrene Militärausgaben. Und da ist es dann halt so, dass die Forderungen für solche Umschuldungsabkommen, nämlich also, dass man weiter Kredit kriegt, indem man halt Kredite konsolidiert oder welche zu niedrigen Zinsen bekommt, ist halt ja Sozialabbau. Also dafür zu sorgen, deshalb die Neokon-Ideologie von irgendwie den startverkleinern, alles privatisieren, Sozialausgaben senken und irgendwie alles dem Markt überlassen und vor allen Dingen auch ausländische Firmen ins Land zu lassen, also halt keinen Protektionismus zu betreiben. Das ist halt so ein klassisches Spiel, was da immer wieder getrieben wird und auch immer wieder zu den selben Resultaten führt.
Das ist ein Drehbuch. Also das ist richtig ein Drehbuch und die haben sogar die Zeiten zwischen den einzelnen Schritten sind inzwischen relativ klar beobachtbar, weil das in so vielen Ländern stattgefunden hat. Man kriegt es ja gar nicht mit, wenn man sich da nicht explizit für interessiert, wie oft dieses Weltbankprogramm schon durchgeführt wurde. Aber das ist so klar, was da passiert am Ende. Also es geht immer damit los, dass man sagt, ihr müsst jetzt privatisieren, Strom, Wasser, Ölindustrie, völlig klar, das muss jetzt hier. Das darf nicht mehr dem Staat gehören. Der Staat muss sparen. Ihr habt Schulden, ist der erste Schritt. So der zweite Schritt ist, ihr müsst den Markt öffnen, damit die Ausländer investieren können. Die Ausländer investieren dann in genau die privatisierte Industrie, die möglicherweise nicht konkurrenzfähig ist, weil sie eben bisher monopol war. Das heißt, die wird üblicherweise billig angeboten, weil sie nämlich nicht konkurrenzfähig ist, sondern ist also die inländische Versorgung, Infrastruktur ist dann erstmal in ausländischer Hand. Und was die als erstes nicht tun, die Ausländer, ist da die Maintenance-Kosten-Zahlen, Wartung. Weil das ist ja viel besser, da den Profit rauszutragen. Der nächste Schritt ist, dass eben das Kapital erstmal reinfließt, um die ganzen Sachen zu kaufen, aber dann eben auch schnell wieder abfließt, wenn sich abzeichnet, dass das passiert halt immer. Das kann man sehen, die Leute wissen das inzwischen. Das heißt, die Investoren ziehen dann auch ab, wenn sie glauben, es ist bald so weit. Und dann muss das Land eben die Zinsen erhöhen, auf die Staatsanleihen, die sie rausgeben, also auf die neuen Schulden. Und die Größenordnung, um die es da geht, sind durchaus so etwas wie 30, 50, 80 Prozent, das hat alles schon gegeben. Die Begründung der Weltbank für die erhöhten Zinsen ist natürlich Investoren anlocken, aber die Investoren sind ja nicht wegen der Zinsen da, sondern um die indländische Industrie aufzukaufen. Und der nächste Punkt nennt sich Market-Based Pricing, das heißt, man darf nicht mehr Grundnahrungsmittel subventionieren, was üblicherweise die letzte Sache ist, die so ein Pleite-Land machen kann, um Aufstände zu verhindern. Wenn man sieht, das wird alles immer teurer, wir haben es privatisiert, die Leute können sich keine Nahrungsmittel mehr kaufen, keinen Strom. Üblicherweise, also wenn wir jetzt in Südamerika, wo es so gut dokumentiert ist, wie das so abläuft, weil das eben noch nicht so lange zurückliegt und weil die auch Presse haben da im Gegensatz zu manchen afrikanischen Ländern. Und da sieht man eben, dass sie mit Gas kochen und dass dann das Gas zu teuer geworden ist. Ja, und da gibt es dann Aufstände. Und dafür gibt es einen Namen innerhalb der Weltbar. Das nennt sich IMF Riot, weil das einfach da kann man die Uhr nachstellen. Das kommt in allen von diesen Ländern, kommt es am Ende zu Ausschreitungen. Und das nennt sich IMF Riot. Und das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Wenn die selber schon ein Wort dafür haben, dass sie Aufstände in den Ländern auslösen, ja, dann darf man sich nicht wundern, was jetzt in Griechenland passiert. Denn wenn wir die Schritte, die ich gerade erwähnt habe, mit dem vergleichen, was wir gerade in Griechenland unter dem der Überschrift von Sparmaßnahmen und Austerity verkaufen, ist es genau das.
Also da muss man sich mal tatsächlich um Detail angucken. Da gibt es ja gerade diese Beschlussverlage für den Bundestag, die da durchgewinkt wurde. Da stehen halt eben auch so ein paar Details drin, was erwartet wird für Griechenland. Und wie halt der Stand auf dem Zeitplan gerade ist, also wie die Umsetzung aussieht. Weil die Abgeordneten, denen es eingeredet worden, dass die Umsetzung dieser Zeitplan von diesen Austerity-Maßnahmen, dass die ganz wichtig sind. Also dass Griechenland sich einen neuen Kredit oder neue Höfe damit verdient, dass sie eben diesen Zeitplan umsetzen. Und da sind dann solche Sachen. Also zum Beispiel wird dann als erstes gefordert, dass sichergestellt wird, dass die Schuldendienstzahlungen, also die Bedienung der Schulden, dass in der griechischen Verfassung verankert wird, dass die Vorrang vor allem anderen bekommen. Das heißt also, bevor die irgendwie ihre Sozialhilfe zahlen können oder irgendwie die Löhne für ihre Beamten oder ihre Lehrer und Ärzte, Feuerwehr müssen sie halt erstmal die Schulden töten. Da drin ist auch eine Liste der Firmen, die zu privatisieren ist. Und das genau nach diesem Weltbank-IMF-Spielplan, nämlich halt irgendwie für alle Firmen, die halt irgendwie groß sind und mit Gas, Wasser, Öl, Glücksspiel, Eisenbahn, Häfen, auch so kleine regionale Häfen, Bergbaufirmen und Konzessionen, Straßen, Staatlichkeiten, Immobilien, die müssen alle privatisiert werden. So und interessant daran ist, da gibt es dann immer zwei Schritte, nämlich zum einen den Transfer dieses Assets, also dieser, was weiß ich, dieser Immobilie oder dieser Firma oder dieses Hafens in eine Treuhandfirma, also entsprechend, wie es halt hier auch in Deutschland war, die Treuhand. Und dann muss, genauso auch in diesem Zeitplan verankert, muss ein Berater dazu angeheuert werden, der sich also darum zu kümmern hat, dass dieses Ding vermarktet und verwertet wird. So und wo kommen denn diese Berater her, fragt man sich da und wenn man ein bisschen nachguckt, dann sieht man wieder mal Goldman Sachs und wieder mal JP Morgan und wieder mal die anderen großen Banken, die sich da halt eine goldene Nase verdienen und sicherstellen, dass eben die wirklich wertvollen Sachen eben für ein Apfel und ein Ei an ihre Auftraggeber gehen.
Das ist ein Raubzug von geradezu historischem Ausmaß. Wenn man sich das anguckt, dann ist das mehr als die Wikinger gebrannt schatzt haben. So auch prozentual, nicht mal nur von der Größe, weil das ist ja klar, das gibt ja bei Menschen heute. Aber also was da gerade passiert ist ein unglaublicher Vorgang und es ist frappierend, wie wenig Leute das mitkriegen.
Was da halt noch passiert ist halt die systematische Absenkung von allen Sozialstandards. Also zum Beispiel steht da drin in diesem Bundestagspapier als Anforderung an Griechenland, dass also der Mindestlohn um 22 Prozent abzusenken ist und der Mindestlohn für Jugendliche um 32 Prozent abzusenken ist. Und außerdem müssen sich die Rechte von Gewerkschaften kastrieren. Das heißt also, die Gewerkschaften dürfen da halt also nicht mehr irgendwie ordentlich streiken und es gibt also auch zum Beispiel keinen Zwang zur Schlichtung mehr. Dass also die Unternehmen können dann, wenn diese Geschichten umgesetzt sind, ja quasi, wenn wir sie nicht machen, was sie wollen. Die Gewerkschaften waren in Griechenland traditionell auch mal sehr stark. Aber die werden halt im Zuge dieser von außen auf oktroyierten Gesetzgebungen jetzt komplett kastriert. Das heißt also, worum es da geht, ist, dass eben diese Schulden dazu benutzt werden, diese Länder quasi zu kolonialisieren.
Was jetzt natürlich aus unserer Perspektive das Spannendste ist, ist, wie sie es schaffen, dass unsere Bevölkerung da nicht so über nachdenkt als Bild so, wir sind hier die brandschätzenden Ausländer, die da einfallen und alles kaputt machen, sondern wie wir das sogar so darstellen, als seien die Griechen selber schuld, weil das ist ja irgendwie das faulste Land Europas und was man da für ein Blödsinn wird. Die Statistik sagt, dass die Griechen sogar mehr arbeiten als die Deutschen pro Woche. Also das ist kompletter Blödsinn und sie verdienen weniger dabei. Also es ist überhaupt nicht so, dass sie das selbst verlinkt haben. Im Gegenteil.
Es ist ja wie immer bei solchen PR-Methoden, ist es ja so, dass durchaus immer eine körnliche Wahrheit dabei ist. Also was denn auch möglichst eins, was die Leute selber erfahren können. Also wenn man mal in Griechenland unterwegs war, dann ist es halt alle schon ein wenig lässiger und entspannter und die Leute arbeiten vielleicht nicht so hart, wenn sie irgendwie auf der Arbeit sind. Dementsprechend ist halt auch die Gesamtproduktivität pro Kopf geringer. Aber was man auch sehen muss, ist, dass Griechenland von seiner Ausgangssituation her eine völlig andere Lage hat als Deutschland. Die sind halt im Wesentlichen auf Tourismus und Rederei und Logistik angewiesen als Einkommensquellen. Vielmehr haben sie halt nicht. Da gibt es eben keine Industrie, die konkurrieren könnte. Sie haben halt auch relativ wenig Wissenschaft und Forschung, die dazu führen würde, dass man halt eine heitliche Industrie aufbauen könnte.
Das haben wir uns auch nicht schätzen.
Da haben sie halt alles probiert. Es ist ja nicht so, dass es keine guten griechischen Universitäten gibt. Aber dabei gegen die Deutschen anzustinken, ist halt quasi unmöglich, weil der Vorsprung halt einfach zu groß ist.
Und weil wir natürlich auch unseren Teil tun, damit die nicht konkurrenzfähig werden. Wir sind ja keine Amateure. Also man kriegt das ja immer nicht so mit als Bürger von Deutschland. Aber unsere Politik ist schon fit darum, wenn es darum geht, Ausländer an die Kandare zu nehmen und zu gucken, dass die nicht zu einer Konkurrenz von uns heranreifen. Also was für mich die krasseste Einsicht an dieser ganzen Nummer ist, dass wir diese Methoden, diese furchtbaren, ein Land in die Pleite und in Unruhensturzmethoden, dass wir diese seit vielen Jahren angewendet haben gegen Ex-Kolonien, irgendwelche afrikanischen Länder, die weit weg waren, wo das Risiko relativ gering war, dass die Bevölkerung mitkriegt, wie schlecht es den Leuten da geht und dass wir schuld sind. Aber dass man diese selben Methoden jetzt auch gegen westliche Länder anwendet, das ist eine neue Qualität an dieser Geschichte. Ich habe das schon vor einer Weile postuliert im Blog, dass die EU eigentlich diesen Effekt hat, aber dass es jetzt tatsächlich der Weltwährungsfonds, das Drehbuch genommen wird und auf Griechenland angewendet wird. Das ist schon eine ausgesprochen krasse Sache. Und wir sehen das alle und keiner tut was. Im Gegenteil, wir legen uns noch unsere Ausflüchte zurecht, warum wir das tun. Also die PR macht ja nichts, die dreht uns ja nicht um, sondern die gibt uns nur Argumente, mit denen wir uns selbst belügen können, dass es schon seine Wichtigkeit hat.
Genau ist ja dieses Argument. Zum einen halt die vorigen Griechen, die sind ja selber schuld. Klar ist halt auch irgendwie, das Geld, was da verbrannt wurde, ist ja eben auch nicht alles irgendwie in Sachen geflossen, von denen die einfach in Griechenland hatten. Da haben auch richtig reiche Leute richtig viel Geld rausgetragen. Also die halt sich einfach Sachen eingesackt haben und Sachen zu überteuerten Preisen gebaut haben. Es ist halt schon ein Land, wo die Korruption durchaus vermutlich etwas endemischer ist als bei uns zumindest im Alltag. Also was man so liest. Und das hat natürlich auch seinen Grund, weil die Korruption auf höchster Ebene eben umso größer ist. Aber das heißt ja trotzdem nicht, dass das ist halt irgendwie genau der Grund ist, dass die Griechenlands alle voll und doof sind, dass sie in die Situation gekommen sind. Sondern es ist halt schon so, dass gerade mit dem Euro hat Deutschland diese Länder durchaus absichtsvoll in eine Position manövriert, wo, wenn sie nicht aufpassen, sie am Ende deutsche Produkte kaufen und dafür von Deutschland gegebenen Krediten zahlen. Oder eben auch von anderen westlichen Ländern gegebenen Krediten zahlen. Also diese China-Rolle innerhalb der EU, die ist aus meiner Sicht kein Zufall. Es ist nicht so, dass es irgendwie einfach passiert ist. Es war ja schon durchaus so, dass als der Euro eingeführt wurde, durchaus ein paar Ökonomen davor gewarnt haben und gesagt haben, so könnte durchaus passieren, weil irgendwie die Produktivität in diesen Ländern geringer ist und die Wirtschaft einfach eine Möglichkeit bräuchte, eigentlich ihre Währung abwerten zu können, damit sie konkurrenzfähig bleiben. Mit dem Euro konnten sie das halt nicht. Also sie waren halt einfach qua Definition im teurer, als sie eigentlich sein müssten. Aber sie haben Zugang zu billigen Krediten bekommen und die haben sie dann auch weitlich ausgenutzt und damit wiederum Kram in Deutschland gekauft. Also ist halt dieser Kreislauf, also diese Herausbildung der deutschen Hegemonie in Europa eben nicht auf der Basis von irgendwie Militär und Waffen, sondern auf der Basis von eines Währungsdesigns. Also dass das irgendwie ein dummer Zufall ist, das kann mir glaube ich keiner mehr erzählen.
Vielleicht ein bisschen Vorgeschichte noch, weil nicht alle Leute irgendwie seit vielen Jahren meinen Blog lesen. Griechenland hat seine Bücher gefälscht, um in die Währungsunion überhaupt reinzukommen. Die sind damit mit falschen Zahlen hingegangen und die EU hat es geprüft und hat gemerkt, dass die Zahlen falsch sind und hat sie trotzdem reingelassen. Also das ist nicht so, dass das alles Zufall ist oder dass man das den Griechen in die Schuhe beschieben kann, sondern wir haben uns hingestellt, haben den Griechen gesagt, hey, ihr wollt hier billig Kredit haben und ich mein, guckt mal in eure Zeitung, dass dieselbe Masche funktioniert in Deutschland auch gegen die Armen in der Bevölkerung. Wir haben hingegangen und gesagt, hier billige Kredite, das wollt ihr doch haben, ihr müsst nur ein bisschen eure Bücher fälschen. Und dann haben die Griechen das gemacht und jetzt stellen wir uns hin und sagen, die scheiß Griechen, nee, wir haben denen das eingebrockt von Anfang an. Es gab dann zwischendurch noch so ein paar witzige Details, die möchte ich hier nochmal der Vollständigkeit habe erwähnen. Es gab da diese Geschichte, dass die, als dann rauskam, offiziell rauskam, dass die Griechen die ganze Zeit ihre Bücher gefälscht haben, haben die Griechen halt angefangen und gesagt, ja, wir erreichen hier den Stabilitätspakt, nicht? Dann werden wir doch einfach mal die Schattenwirtschaft mitzählen und haben gesagt, ja, wir haben hier Prostitutionen, wir haben hier Geldwäsche, wir haben hier Drogenhandel und haben einfach 25 Prozent auf ihre Industriegröße drauf gerechnet, um den Stabilitätspakt zu erreichen. Und da gab es irgendwie ein paar Schlagzeilen in der Bild damals, aber ansonsten sind sie damit durchgekommen. Und da hat auch keiner was gesagt, weil nämlich die Hauptprofiteure davon sind nicht die Griechen, sondern wir. Das ist der Punkt, den ich hier nach Hause tragen möchte. Das ist nicht so, dass die Griechen von diesem ganzen Konstrukt profitieren. Im Gegenteil, die sind ausgeblutet jetzt und zwar in unsere Richtung. Dass wir diese ganzen Rezessionen so gut überlebt haben, liegt unter anderem daran, dass wir den Griechen ihr Geld weggenommen haben.
Also, weil man dabei immer noch klassifizieren muss, wir sind halt nicht irgendwie du und ich.
Na ja, über Bande sind wir das schon auch über. Das ist unsere Regierung. Dann können wir uns nicht so rausreden jetzt einfach.
Na gut, das sind halt aber auch einfach die deutschen Banken. Und die deutsche Industrie. Das ist halt nicht so, dass irgendwie dieses Geld der deutschen Bevölkerung zugute gekommen wäre. Im Gegenteil, wenn man sich die Veränderung der Einkommensverteilung anguckt. Dann ist es halt irgendwie eine sehr kleine Minderheit, bei der das Geld gelandet ist. Also diese ganze Griechenlandnummer ist halt wiederum nur eine Ausprägung, der seit irgendwie so was wie 15 Jahren in Betrieb seinen Gelddiode, die halt dazu führt, dass das Geld von unten nach oben verteilt wird und eben auch von den ärmeren Ländern zu den reichen, aber in den reichen Ländern eben auch wiederum nicht zu allen Leuten, sondern halt primär irgendwie zu den reichen Leuten.
Ja, natürlich. Also ich will auch nicht sagen, dass wir jetzt irgendwie die Profiteure sind, sondern wir hätten es verhindern können.
Plus spannend daran ist ja eben genau diese Argumentation, dass eben dann immer versucht wird zu sagen, naja, also wenn Griechenland jetzt zusammenbricht, dann irgendwie kollabieren auch die Bundesschatzbriefe und dann sind auch Rentenfonds, aus denen das Geld kommt. Deswegen müssen wir auf die Rückzahlung pochen. Und dann gibt es halt noch so diese Argumentation, die versucht, irgendwie da so einen neuen Nationalismus aufzubauen, indem man halt sagt, so die deutschen Interessen sind halt irgendwie die kongruent mit denen der deutschen Banken, was quasi der Subtext dazu ist. Da muss man halt echt genau hingucken. Also weil da versucht wird, mit Argumenten zu hantieren, die schlicht nicht wahr sind. Also dass die deutschen Lebensversicherungen irgendwie nichts mehr wert sind, hat primär damit zu tun, dass sich die Banken verzockt haben. Also wenn sie halt irgendwie da nicht diese Spiele gespielt hätten, sondern es halt nur, sagen wir mal, bei dieser Griechenland-Ausbeutung belassen hätten oder bei dieser Ausbeutung der EU-Ranstaaten, dann würde es uns allen wahrscheinlich total toll gehen gerade.
Also zwei Transferleistungen möchte ich an der Stelle einfordern. Erstens, wenn wir sagen, die Banken haben sich verzockt, das Geld ist ja an andere Banken geflossen. Das heißt, als Bonus von den Zocker-Abteilungen von den jeweiligen Banken dann rausgegangen. Die Investment-Abteilungen haben Geld verloren und die Zocker-Abteilungen haben es eingenommen und sich selbst als Bonus ausgezahlt. Also die Banker haben uns ausgeraubt. Und die zweite Transferlastung. Die Argumente, die jetzt gegen die Griechen kommen, sind dieselben, mit denen vorher der Sarrazin bei uns versucht hat, gegen die Ausländer zu bashen im Land. Das ist immer dieselbe Scheiße, mit der gegen dieselben Randgruppen, die sich nicht wehren können, argumentiert wird. Und das mögen bitte mal alle zur Kenntnis nehmen. Das ist die billigste Scheiß-Rhetorik, die hier verwendet wird. Und da darf man, das muss man als das sehen, was es ist. Das hat nichts mit Argumenten zu tun. Das ist reine Volksverhetzung. Spannend ist jetzt allerdings, wie es weitergehen soll natürlich.
Ja klar, also meine, die Argumentation, wieso Griechenland nicht einfach einen geordneten Staatsbankrott machen kann und sagt, ok, dann war es es halt mit den Schulden, ist ja eben dieses Jahr, das vergessen die Märkte nie, so niemand wird irgendwie dem Land wieder Geld borken. So und irgendwie also sozusagen die Verweigerung eines geordneten Rückzugs aus dem Euro und halt zu sagen, naja gut, dann hat eben keine, vergessen wir halt diese Staatsschulden. Die hat eben auch eine Menge mit der Interessensverflechtung zu tun, wo wir wieder zum Anfang zurückkommen, zwischen den Banken und der Politik und also den, bzw. den Besitzern großer Geldmengen. Die Banken sind ja nicht zwingend die Besitzer dieser großen Geldmengen, sondern eben häufig nur die Verwalter, sondern den Besitzer der großen Vermögen und der Politik. Und denen würde es halt eben ans Leder gehen, weil eben wenn halt irgendwie die Märkte dann mal zwischendurch kollabieren, so dann würden halt weniger die Leute verlieren, die halt irgendwie normales Einkommen bekommen und möglicherweise, wie wir früher mal ein paar Apple-Aktien hatten, sondern eben die Leute, die halt auf großen Vermögen sitzen, weil die wissen halt eben nicht mehr, wohin mit ihrem Geld und wie sie es anlegen sollen, ohne dass sie Sachen verlieren. Und dementsprechend wird eben auch die Politik geformt, also um halt zu verhindern, dass diese Leute ernsthaft Geld verlieren.
Es gibt auch Gegenbeispiele. Wir haben jetzt die ganzen Länder zusammengefasst, die auf die Weltwährungsfonds und Weltbankpolitik reingefallen sind und da die Opfer sind. Es gibt auch Gegenbeispiele. Das sind allerdings alles Länder bisher mit großen Bodenschätzen. Also es gab auf der einen Seite sowas wie Venezuela, die auf großen Ölreserven sitzen und die haben sich das leisten können, einfach die Kredite nicht anzunehmen. Das andere Gegenbeispiel ist Island, die eben Geothermie haben und damit praktisch kostenlose Energie. Das ist natürlich auch eine Voraussetzung, mit der man sagen kann, ok, stinke Finger.
Meine Island ist durchaus interessant. Da sollten wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen darauf eingehen, was in Island passiert ist. Island hatte ja zwei große Banken, die über ihre Töchter billige Kredite ausgegeben haben und hohe Zinsen für Einlagen versprochen haben. Der Hintergrund davon ist halt der, dass die quasi ausgenutzt haben, dass Island ein souveränes Land mit einer eigenen Währung ist und sie darauf gezockt haben, dass wenn irgendwas schief geht, dann wird sich der isländische Staat schon bailouten. Es ging halt schief, sie haben sich verzockt und sie haben jede Menge Geld rausgetragen. Sie haben tatsächlich ihre eigenen Banken ausgeplündert. Und nachdem jetzt halt irgendwie da in Amelie die Hypothekenblase geplatzt ist und die sie unter anderem investiert haben, waren diese Banken halt quasi insolvent und konnten halt ihre Einlagen nicht mehr auszahlen. Und dann haben halt insbesondere die holländischen und die britischen Staaten verlangt, dass der isländische Einlagen-Sicherungsfonds für diese Einlagen gerade steht. Da waren halt irgendwie ein paar Zehntausende Holländer und Briten und auch eine Menge Deutsche, die da halt Geld gebunkert hatten, zu ziemlich utopischen Zinsen. Ich glaube, es war so was wie 5,5 und 7 Prozent oder wie so was. Und also Zinsen, wo man sich schon so denken musste, so hä, wie können die denn zahlen?
Ich glaube, das ging sogar bis 9 Prozent tot. Das war echt unglaubwürdig.
Ja, es war jedenfalls so wie so hä. Und so, und am Ende war es dann halt so, dass die Großbritannien und die Herländer wollten Island mit massivsten, also wirklich massivsten, diplomatischen Druck dazu bringen, diese Verantwortung zu akzeptieren. Das heißt also halt irgendwie als Staat zu sagen, okay, wir stehen dafür gerade für diese Banken, die da pleite gegangen sind. Und wir, wir nehmen halt im Zweifel den Kredit auf und zahlen irgendwie diese Einlagen zurück. Und dann müssen halt alle Islander abzahlen, bis irgendwie in drei Generationen, um bezutilgen.
Das alte Spiel, wenn man das nochmal sagen dürfen, an der Stelle, der Spruch ist zwar blöd, aber ich mag ihn. Die Profite werden privatisiert und die Verluste werden sozialisiert. Das trägt dann die Vergabe, wie das so läuft im Kapitalismus.
Und interessanterweise waren diese Abkommen sogar schon unterschriftsreif.
Die waren sogar teilweise auch schon unterschrieben.
Genau, die Regierung hatte die halt schon unterschrieben und dann musste, hätte das Parlament die noch ratifizieren sollen. Und zwischendurch war aber in Island halt die Regierung gestürzt und das Parlament komplett neu gewählt worden. Und da sind halt durchaus, also in Island ist halt eine sehr, sehr überschaubare Gesellschaft. Also es ist halt sehr klein, sehr, sehr nah. Also alle kennen sich eigentlich und man weiß eigentlich von jedem, wer er ist und wer mit wem er zusammenhängt und so. Und das heißt also, alle diese Konflikte sind halt auch immer unglaublich persönlich. Also es ist halt nicht so abstrakt wie hier so, was ist nicht die CDU oder so, sondern irgendwie die entsprechende Partei ist dann halt irgendwie der Nachbar von irgendwie fünf Häuser die Straße runter und seine Kumpels. Das heißt also, man kennt sich halt doch sehr detailliert.
So ungefähr 300.000 Einwohner, das ist so viel wie Hannover, schätze ich mal.
Ach so ungefähr. Und dann gab es halt eine Volksabstimmung und in der Volksabstimmung, die halt extrem kontrovers war, also für isländische Verhältnisse geradezu aggressiv geführte Argumentationen, also von wegen eben dann auch die Argumente, wir müssen es jetzt machen, weil sonst kriegen wir nie wieder Geld und werden aus der internationalen Gemeinschaft ausgestoßen. Und so waren halt die Argumente und wir werden irgendwie komplett untergehen. Und auf der anderen Seite waren halt die Leute gesagt, naja, also wenn wir jetzt diese Schulden akzeptieren als Gesellschaft, so dann haben wir quasi mehrere Jahre Einkommen pro Kopf, die wir abzahlen müssen. Und das heißt, der isländische Staat hat halt einfach dann gar kein Geld mehr, so überhaupt nicht mehr. Und alles muss privatisiert werden und alles muss irgendwie an den ausländischen Investoren verkauft werden. Und dann hat das Volk dagegen entschieden in der Volksabstimmung. Das heißt, das Volk hat gesagt, nee, wollen wir nicht. So ist doch egal, wenn wir keine Kredite mehr kriegen, besser als irgendwie auf Jahrzehnte hinweg irgendwie da in Knechtschaft sein.
Also die Wahl war, die Banden zu retten, damit die der Bevölkerung ihr Geld zurückgeben können oder die Bevölkerung retten.
Nein, nicht mal der inländischen Bevölkerung ihr Geld zurückgeben können, sondern primär der ausländischen Bevölkerung ihr Geld zurückgeben können.
Ja, natürlich. Aber also generell, ich finde, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Wenn man die ausländische Bevölkerung, kann man auch komplett rauslassen aus der Überlegung und trotzdem zu dem Schluss kommen, wenn ich die Wahl habe, ob ich die Banken retten soll, weil sonst irgendwelche Bürger betroffen sind oder ob ich lieber die Bürger rette, die dann betroffen wären. Dann sollte eigentlich jedes Land immer sagen, ich rette lieber die Bürger. Denn das ist ja ein zentraler Hebelkreislauf in der Wirtschaft, dass man sagt, wenn man verhindert, dass die Bank die Scheiße baut, pleite geht, dann wird sie natürlich weiter Scheiße bauen. Sie wird so noch mehr Scheiße bauen als bisher, weil sie jetzt weiß, dass sie nicht mehr haften muss dafür. Also das ist eine Sache, die hätte auch bei uns so entschieden werden müssen, wurde aber nicht.
Genau, aber interessant daran ist halt, was passiert ist. Island steht heute besser da als irgendwie zum Beispiel Irland, die halt in einer ähnlichen vergleichbaren Scheißsituation waren. Also Island bekommt tatsächlich wieder Kredite, zwar nur von zwei Banken, aber immerhin. Und sie haben es halt geschafft, irgendwie quasi ihre politische Selbstständigkeit zu behalten. Und interessanterweise denken sie gerade nicht darüber nach, irgendwie sich der EU anzuschließen, sondern sie überlegen tatsächlich, ob sie sich zum Beispiel ihre Währung an den kanadischen Dollar ankoppeln können.
Das kann ich wirklich nachvollziehen, gerade muss ich sagen. Also auch die Schweiz, ich finde das ausgesprochen sinnvoll, nicht der EU beizutreten. Gerade das würde ich mit Sicherheit auch nicht tun an deren Stelle.
Naja, da sind wir sozusagen beim Stand der Geldpolitik. Also was wir da gerade sehen, also gerade was Merkel da treibt, das treibt mir mittlerweile echt so die Zornesröte ins Gesicht. Also was war die Meldung heute, dass sie sich aktiv in den französischen Wahlkampf einmischt, um zu verhindern, dass der Konkurrent von Sarkozy an die Macht kommt, der angesagt hat, dass er also a. diese ganzen Bailout und sonstigen Verträge nochmal nachverhandeln will und b. dass er eine reichen Steuer einführen will, die halt irgendwie die Steuerquote bis 75 Prozent hoch treibt für wirklich reiche Leute. Also jetzt nicht nur für ein paar Zehntausende oder hunderttausend, sondern für wirklich reiche Leute. Also quasi Sachen, die halt, also naja.
Der Mann ist halt Sozialist, ja?
Ja, der ist Sozialist. Da denkt man halt irgendwie, das ist halt irgendwie das, was man gerade tun müsste so. Und was jetzt passiert ist irgendwie, dass irgendwie die Merkel und irgendwie die italienische Regierung, die von den Deutschen eingesetzt wurde und irgendwie Blair und die Spanier gesagt haben, dass sie mit dem Hollande, also dem Konkurrenten von Sarkozy, nichts zu tun haben wollen und die nicht empfangen werden, weil sie Sarkozy stützen wollen. Und das ist halt ein Level von Aufkündigung von zivilisatorischen Grundsätzen zwischen Ländern, wo man eigentlich sagen muss, okay, in die Innenpolitik, gerade in den Wahlkampf, mischt man sich einfach nicht ein. So man redet halt irgendwie ganz klar in der Außenpolitik mit den Leuten, die halt da gewählt wurden. Und wenn das Land halt irgendwie einen Sozialisten will, der 75 Prozent Reichensteuer will, dann geht man halt irgendwie politisch damit um. Aber nein, was da versucht wird, ist die aktive Beeinflussung von Politik. So und ich meine gerade, was jetzt in Italien passiert ist, ich meine, gut, zwar Berlusconi, der absolviert wurde, aber de facto hat Deutschland da die Regierung absolviert, um halt irgendwie da Wohlgefallen zu erzeugen. Und genau dasselbe wird halt in Griechenland passieren. Und jetzt versuchen sie sogar, in Frankreich, also dafür zu sorgen, dass eben da derjenige, der halt irgendwie dem Diktat irgendwie der reichen folgt, nämlich irgendwie Sarkozy, der nur weil er irgendwie gut mit Merkel kann, da am Ruder bleiben soll.
Ich möchte das noch ein bisschen anders betrachten, denn es ist tatsächlich auch hier ein Präzedenzfall. Wir haben das auch viele Jahre mit irgendwelchen Afrikanern, also jetzt nicht wir als die Deutschen, aber die europäischen Mächte haben das jahrelang genauso in Afrika gemacht. Da haben wir doch einen Scheiß drauf gegeben, was die Bevölkerung wählen wollte. So und den Punkt, den ich vorhin mit Griechenland gemacht habe, der gilt natürlich genauso für Italien und Frankreich. Wir sehen die jetzt einfach nicht mehr als westliche Macht gerade, sondern wir sehen die wie so ein afrikanisches Pleite-Land, wie eine Kolonie, die wir halt so behandeln können. Das ist ja nicht, wenn wir jetzt hier groß traben, von irgendwelchen zivilisatorischen Grundvoraussetzungen reden, die haben wir früher auch ignoriert. Es ging halt um andere Länder. Diese Schranke ist gewichen. Früher haben wir sowas halt nur mit irgendwelchen, also ich sag jetzt mal provokant, Untermenschen gemacht. Leute, auf die wir herabgeblickt haben, in irgendwelchen fremden, weit weg Ländern, nur gesagt haben, naja, die sind eh nicht auf einem Niveau mit uns.
Und vor allen Dingen, wo es halt einfach keine Berichterstattung gab. Dieses weit weg Konstrukt ist ja eben auch durchaus ein Medienkonstrukt. Also genauso gut könnte man halt irgendwie aus Kongo oder irgendwie Usbekistan oder sowas halt auch mal detailliert berichten und mal erzählen, was da westliche Politik anrichtet. Aber stattdessen wird das halt eben als ist weit weg und interessiert sich niemand dargestellt.
Ich sehe das auch immer so ein bisschen aus dem Manipulationsblickwinkel, zu dem ich auch gleich noch ein paar Sachen sagen möchte. Denn letztendlich geht es bei der PR gar nicht so darum, dich zu überzeugen, sondern es geht ja um Sachen, die in deinem Interesse sind als Bürger. Das ist ja in unserem Interesse, wenn Frankreich hier irgendwie nicht souverän ist. Es ist zwar kein schönes Interesse und es ist auch nicht kommunistisch. Eigentlich möchten wir gerne bestimmen, wo es langgeht. Das ist doch klar.
In dem Fall ist aber wir wieder tatsächlich die Leute, die auf dem Geld sitzen. Natürlich. Nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise demokratisch legitimiert. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass wir sagen könnten, der Bundestag als Ausdruck unserer demokratischen Volksvertretung hat auch nicht irgendeinen Einfluss, sondern es ist tatsächlich so, dass da Politik durchgesetzt wird, die mit unseren Interessen als Bürger einfach mal genau gar nichts zu tun hat, sondern eben ein abstraktes nationales Interesse, was formuliert wird, aber de facto eben nur das Interesse von einigen sehr wenigen einflussreichenden Reichen in diesem Land ist.
Ja, aber der Punkt ist doch, deswegen bin ich ja nicht im Zirkel schluss...
Deswegen stürm ich keine Lust an deinem Wir, weißt du, deswegen...
Nein, ich sage das aufsichtliche als Wir, weil das nämlich genau der Mechanismus ist, der hier benutzt wird. Das ist wie, wenn man eine Lotterie macht. Die Leute reden sich ein, ich könnte das ja auch erreichen. Genau dieses Mittelstand und Unterschichtdings, dass die Leute alle glauben, alle Leute in der Unterschicht glauben, sie seien in der Mittelschicht. Und alle Leute haben dieses irrationale Gefühl, sie könnten ja auch irgendwann zu den Superreichen gehören. Das ist dieser amerikanische Traum. Gut, ich bin jetzt hier ein bisschen beeinflusst gerade, weil ich in Amerika bin. Aber das ist ein ganz altes psychologisches Prinzip, dass man einfach weniger hart gegen die Reichen vorgeht, weil man denkt, ich könnte ja auch reich sein demnächst. Und es geht bei der PR eben nicht so darum, dass man tatsächlich die Leute überzeugt, sondern dass man ihnen Munition gibt, mit der sie sich selbst bewegen können. Man sagt, wenn ich hier von Untermenschen rede, dann ist es ja auch nicht unsere offizielle Politik oder gar meine Einschätzung zu diesen Leuten, sondern das ist die Ausrede, die man den Rassisten geben kann, damit sie sich vor sich selbst dieses Thema nicht so bearbeiten. Es kann ja niemand mit offenem Gewissen das dulden, was wir gemacht haben mit irgendwelchen Ländern, die wir da ausnutzen. Ob das jetzt in Afrika oder Griechenland, es ist ja letztendlich wurscht. Aber dass das jetzt so ein qualitativer Unterschied ist, es sollte uns alle furchtbar bedrücken, finde ich. Denn es hat ja keine Sau bei uns irgendwas gesagt, als die ganzen afrikanischen Länder da in die Pleite gewirtschaftet und kaputt gemacht wurden. Da gibt es dann halt Spendenaufrufe. Aber diese Manipulation funktioniert eigentlich immer so, dass man A, den Leuten einredet bzw. hilft, es sich selbst einzureden, dass sie auch selbst bald reich sein könnten. Und dann sind sie nämlich die Nutznieser von dieser ganzen Geschichte. Deswegen auch immer diese Rhetorie gegen die Unterschichten. Sofern wir ein Jahr Hartz IV, die haben es ja alle selber verdient. Das reden sich ja sogar die Hartz IV-Leute teilweise inzwischen selber ein, dass sie selber schuld sind. Also das ist einfach, das ist alles ein Teil von der PR und wie man die Leute manipuliert. Ja, ich habe hier noch ein paar Prinzipien. Ich möchte das ein paar Sachen auch noch ausräumen. Also eine Sache, die ich immer gedacht habe, als ich jünger war, dachte ich ja, also wenn ich Politiker wäre und da käme so ein Lobbyist und der würde mir eine Million anbieten, die können wir doch einfach nehmen und dann nicht tun, was der Lobbyist sagt. Man muss sich ja nicht verpflichtet fühlen. Ja, das ist doch so eine Sache, die man sich überlebt, oder? Und das stimmt halt überhaupt nicht. Also ich hatte bei der Alternativlos Sendung 9 schon so ein Buch geplagt von dem Influence, heißt das Buch. Kann ich nur noch mal plagen. Ich möchte das diesmal noch ein bisschen zusammenfassen, um zu zeigen, mit was für Mitteln. Wie man da gearbeitet wird und wie wir auch alles selber anfällig sind. Also einerseits die Lobbyisten arbeiten so gegenüber den Politikern, andererseits die Politiker arbeiten so gegenüber uns. Und ich möchte vor allem den Punkt machen, dass Korruption gar nicht notwendig ist für den ganzen Weg, um einen Politiker zu überzeugen, sondern man wendet ja erst die anderen Methoden an. Und für den letzten Schritt nimmt man dann vielleicht Korruption, wenn es nötig ist, was in vielen Fällen gar nicht der Fall ist. Denn es gibt ja heutzutage auch so etwas wie die Bertelsmann Stiftung, die es geschafft hat, wie die Bevölkerung bestimmte Dinge sieht, einfach mal komplett umzudrehen. Das heißt, man muss die Leute gar nicht überzeugen, wenn man sie schon überzeugt hat, weil man einfach die Schulbücher geschrieben hat, mit denen sie gelernt haben.
Und eben auch die grundlegenden Ideen gesetzt hat. Also ich meine genau dasselbe. Also genau das ist jetzt zum Beispiel mit den Neokons passiert, wo einfach eingeredet wurde und wo auch eine Menge Intellektuelle mitgemacht haben und diese Marktleubigkeit einfach zur quasi Gesellschaftsideologie wurde und zum Teil ja immer noch ist. Und es halt quasi gegen diese Orthodoxie auch keine Gegenrede gibt, sondern einfach man sagte ja, naja, war halt ein bisschen scheiße mit den Märkten, aber im Prinzip ist ja immer noch das Beste, was wir haben. Und niemand ernsthaft drüber nachdenkt zu sagen, okay, wie wäre es denn mal, wenn wir sagen, okay, Märkte müssen reguliert werden und zwar so drastisch, dass es keinen Spaß mehr macht, da irgendwie Unsinn zu treiben.
Dabei scheitern die Märkte die ganze Zeit vor sich hin. Das merkt nur keiner. Das ist auch ständig in der Presse, wenn man mal darauf achtet. Gibt es ständig irgendwelche Beispiele dafür, dass wieder irgendwelche Sachen gescheitert sind. Und das ist einfach alles ein großer Mythos. Aber wir reden uns das selber ein, weil wir nämlich nur mit diesen Märkten und diesen, auch die Börsen sind ja im Grunde rumgezockt. Aber wir dulden das, weil wir uns selbst einreden. Wir könnten eines Tages der Nutzen-Nieser davon sein.
Ich glaube, es hat eher zwei Aspekte. Der eine ist, dass die Alternative immer noch nur, der gescheiterte reale Existenz Sozialismus zu sein scheint. Durchaus eine Menge anderer Alternativen gäbe, wo man einfach drüber nachdenken könnte, wenn man aus diesem ideologischen Pad herausspringen könnte. Und zum anderen ist es, denke ich, mal so, dass diese Argumente, die da gebracht werden, also dass Märkte effizient sind, dass sie in der Lage sind, Ungleichgewichte auszugleichen, dass sie halt schnell sind, dass sie daraus irgendwie durchaus auch positive Sachen erwachsen können. Die sind ja zum Teil durchaus wahr. Es ist ja nicht so, dass Märkte überhaupt nicht funktionieren. Sie funktionieren nur für bestimmte Dinge nicht. Sie funktionieren halt für eine ganze Menge Sachen nicht und sie gehören halt eng reguliert. Und diesen Punkt, dass man halt also nicht alles in Bausch und Bogen verdammen darf, sondern sagen muss, okay, Märkte sind halt ein Werkzeug, was man gezielt benutzen kann für bestimmte Aufgaben in der Gesellschaft. Aber bei anderen Sachen müssen wir zum Beispiel vielleicht drüber nachdenken, ob wir einfach mal ein Primat der Menschenrechte oder ein Primat irgendwie der Grundrechte nach vorne stellen und nicht nur irgendwie sagen, okay, das Recht auf Reichtum oder die überhaupt die Chance auf Lotto gewinnen oder Reichtum. Dürfen halt alles regieren. Diese Diskussion findet halt momentan außerhalb von Occupy oder so nicht wirklich statt. Und das, glaube ich, mal denke, das ist so ein Punkt, wo eben die PR und auch durchaus die Presse einen ziemlichen Anteil daran hat, weil sie eben solche Diskussionen nicht zulassen, sondern immer gleich dann, sobald jemand die Märkte in Zweifel stellt, den als Spinner oder da in diese Ecke abstellt und aber nicht irgendwie eine ernsthafte, grundlegende Diskussion darüber stattfindet, was man denn da eigentlich mal ändern könnte und wie man halt so eine Regulierung zum Beispiel durchziehen könnte.
Ja, genau. Gut, also ich will noch ein paar Sachen aufzählen, die mich besonders betroffen haben, als ich sie gelesen habe. Weil ich einfach gemerkt habe, dass das bei mir auch funktioniert oder zumindest teilweise, dass es versucht wird, bei mir anzuwenden. Also das erste ist ein Experiment von Ellen Langer. Ich weiß nicht, ob es in Deutsch ist. Die hat geprüft, ob Menschen, also das geht tatsächlich um Experimente, das jetzt nicht irgendwie Hörensagen, sondern es sind klinische Experimente in kontrollierter Umgebung. Und da hat sich herausgestellt, dass Menschen, wenn man eine Sache von ihnen fordert, die sie nicht tun wollen, dass sie dann eher bereit sind, das zu tun, wenn man ihnen eine Begründung gibt, unabhängig davon, ob die Begründung einen Sinn ergibt oder nicht. Alleine die Präsenz einer Begründung triggert schon einen automatischen Mechanismus, der einen dazu bringt, eher zuzustimmen. Und wenn ihr euch mal überlegt, wie viel Begründung ihr von Politikern so hört, die überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben und wo auch die Presse nicht nachfragt, ja, wie das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, das hängt mit Sicherheit teilweise mit dieser Sache zusammen. Also da muss man aufpassen und das muss man einfach wütend werden. Man muss sich einen Zaun aufbauen, wenn einer versucht, einen mit einer sinnlosen Erklärung abzukanzeln.
Diese Konsistenz von so Weltbildern und Modellen, die sollten einen eigentlich auch immer misstrauisch machen. Also wenn man halt so ein...
So Zirkelschluss-Dinger meinst du?
Nee, überhaupt einfach so in sich geschlossene Weltbilder, die also durchaus komplett plausibel klingen, keine Widersprüche aufweisen und nicht an irgendeiner Stelle, man sagen muss ja, hm, ist schwierig oder da gibt's Shades of Grey oder so. Da muss man immer misstrauisch werden. Also in dem Fall, also gerade bei solchen Markttheorien und so, ist es ja ganz evident, dass das irgendwie ein in sich geschlossenes Weltbild ist, was irgendwie alle Anteile, alle Anzeichen einer fundamentalistischen Weltanschauung aufweist.
Ja, genau. Gut, ich hab hier noch so eine Liste mit ein paar Sachen, die ich noch kurz anbrechen wollte. Also erstens, commitment nennt er das als, oder consistency. Wenn man jemanden dazu kriegt, dass er einer Sache zustimmt, am besten schriftlich, dann kann man danach auch den Preis erhöhen und derjenige wird sich trotzdem an die Zustimmung gebunden fühlen. Das funktioniert natürlich mit beliebigen Preiserhöhungen, aber das sieht man in...
So ein bisschen Rahm so hier.
Ja, aber man sieht das beim Verkauf, wenn dann so Sachen kommen, wie ach, es gibt da noch diese eine Gebühr, die habe ich vorhin zu erwähnen vergessen. Oder da kommt noch...
Der Flugreisen oder so, der hat auch zu schlafen.
Und dann hat man sich aber, naja, ich habe jetzt aber schon gesagt, dass ich einen Urlaub machen will, so na gut, dann nehme ich das halt mit. Und genau das gibt es in der Politik auch, dass man nämlich immer diese ganzen Gesetzentwürfe, wo in letzter Minute noch irgendwelche Änderungen gemacht werden, nachdem der Großteil der Politiker schon zugestimmt hat. Und die haben dann auch überhaupt keinen Bock, sich das nochmal anzusehen, weil sie haben ja schon ja gesagt. Und natürlich müssten die eigentlich alle hingehen und sich das nochmal komplett durchlesen, aber das macht halt niemand. Und das ist so ein psychologischer Effekt, der sich ausnutzen lässt. Ja, eine andere Sache nennt sich Kontrast. Das ist beim beim Autoverkäufer, der bietet zuerst die ganz teuren Extras an, die keiner haben will und geht dann auf die weniger kostspieligen hin. Und der der Kunde, für den sehen die dann billig aus im Vergleich, weil er halt den Kontrast hat. Und genau das gibt es in der Politik auch. Der Schäuble ist da der Oberkandidat. Der rennt halt immer los, fordert viel mehr als er eigentlich haben will. Das wird ihm dann abgeschossen und dann lässt er sich freundschaftlicher runterhandeln auf etwas, was immer noch deutlich über dem liegt, was er eigentlich gebraucht hätte. Also das funktioniert auch. Das ist ein Mechanismus, die eigentlich so gebraucht Wagenhändler benutzen. Aber das gibt es eben in der Politik auch.
Eigentlich ist es durchaus ein Wunder, warum so wenig Gebrauchtautoverkäufe in der Politik landen. Oder muss man sich mal Politiker, Biografien daraufhin gezielt angucken?
Ich glaube, das ist einfach... Die haben so ein gewisses Selbst-Ehre, Selbstwertgefühl, haben die gebraucht Wagenhändler noch. Das nächste ist auch so eine Sache vom Autohändler. Das ist eine verwandte Sache. Also wenn der Autohändler von sich aus irgendwas kostenlos anbietet, dann extra. Das ist bei uns schon im Preis drin. Oder überhaupt ein Geschenkmarkt. Der Lacher ist, dass es überhaupt nicht von der Größe des Geschenks abhängt. Wenn man jemandem ein Geschenk macht, fühlt er sich genötigt, die Schuld zu begleichen. Und auch eine Probefahrt ist schon ein Geschenk. Oder eine Tasse Kaffee oder Kekse oder Werbegeschenke.
So Kühlschreiber und so ein Scheiß.
Free Sample, genau. Das führt indirekt dazu, dass die Leute sich selbst gegenüber das Gefühl haben, eine Schuld aufgebaut zu haben und die dann lieber überbegleichen, weil sie einfach überhaupt nicht in die Nähe kommen wollen von irgendwelchen Situationen, wo man in der Gesellschaft als Aussätziger behandelt wird, wenn man Schulden nicht zurückgezahlt hat.
Lobbyisten machen so weiter, indem sie zum Beispiel halt einfach Studien liefern oder Argumente oder auch einfach Wortschöpfungen, mit denen der Politiker halt irgendwie seinen Job einfacher machen kann. Also indem er ihnen quasi die Arbeit leichter macht, gibt er ihnen ein Geschenk, was dann irgendwann zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt halt dann mal quasi inherent eingefordert wird.
Das erklärt aber auch noch ein anderes Phänomen, was mich eine lange Zeit irritiert hat. Wenn man jetzt beim Wulff sieht oder ähnliche frühere Fälle, was da für eine Pille-Palette dem geschenkt wurde, die er sich mühelos mit der Portokasse hätte leisten können.
Also ein Hotel-Dings oder sowas.
Ja, und so ein Hotel ist doch lächerlich. Oder ihn von hier nach da gefahren oder von mir aus, sei es auch der private, das kostet jetzt ein bisschen mehr Geld. Aber da nichts davon, ja, der Mann wird ja fürstlich entlohnt als Präsident, als Bundespräsident und auch in seiner Zeit als Niedersächsischer Regierungschef.
Musste auch nicht hungern, ne?
Nein, der musste nicht hungern. Der hätte sich das alles auch einfach kaufen können. Aber das spielt eben keine Rolle, wie hoch das Geschenk ist, sondern allein die Tatsache, dass es ein Geschenk ist, man muss nur so eine Mindestgrenze überschreiten, vor der die Leute direkt das Gefühl haben, sie werden ja grad missbraucht. Aber spannenderweise funktioniert das auch, wenn man glaubt, dass man missbraucht wird, nur halt zum geringeren Anteil. In diesem Buch, was ich da nochmal verlinken werde, gibt es ein schönes Beispiel von Hare Krishnas, die am Flughafen rumstanden und den Passanten eben ihr Pamphlet in die Hand drücken wollten, diese kostenlosen Bücher, genau, das stehen immer zu großen Stapeln. Und keiner will diese Bücher haben. Also haben die angefangen, so Papier-Falt-Blümchen zu machen und haben halt den Passanten diese Blümchen in die Hand gegeben. Und wenn ein Passant das genommen hat, dann hat er sich verpflichtet gefühlt, auch das Buch mitzunehmen, was man ihm dann als nächstes in die Hand gedrückt hat.
Oder sich ein Gespräch verwickeln zu lassen.
Ja, und das funktioniert erschütternd gut. Also der beschreibt in diesem Buch, wie sie das halt beobachtet haben, wissenschaftlich und gesehen haben, wie die Leute dann diese Blümchen in den nächsten Mülleimer geworfen haben, weil sie von vornherein die nicht haben wollten natürlich. Aber nicht, weil das spielt eine Rolle. Und dann haben die Harakristen das die wieder rausgucken aus dem Mülleimer und den nächsten in den Yard gedrückt. Weil es überhaupt nicht um diese Blume geht. Ja, aber trotz dieser Details funktioniert das. Das muss man sich vor Augen halten. Und das ist eine mächtige Sache, um Leute zu manipulieren. Und das tun die Lobbyisten mit Politikern, die wahrscheinlich in den meisten Fällen überhaupt nicht diese Mechanismen verstanden haben. Also dieses Argument von Wegen, ich würde mich aber nicht verpflichtet fühlen, dann irgendwelche Gegner zu bringen, das stimmt einfach nicht. Das muss man hinnehmen. Das ist nicht der Fall.
Naja, und diese Mechanismen, also diese doch durchaus einfache psychologische Mechanismen sind, die werden natürlich dann auch irgendwie extensiv ausgebeutet. Also ich glaube, wenn man Politik verstehen will, dann lohnt es sich tatsächlich, sich mal mit dem Gebrauchtautohändler über seine Tricks zu unterhalten.
Unbedingt, unbedingt. Also es gibt auch noch Überbandemechanismen, die auch sehr spannend sind. Also nehmen wir mal an, der Händler kommt und bietet einem teures Auto an und lässt sich dann auf ein billigeres herunterhandeln. Dann hat er es auf der einen Seite Zufriedenheit, denn ich habe gerade, ich habe ihn runtergehandelt, und auf der anderen Seite erzeugt es aber einen Druck bei mir, dieses Angebot tatsächlich anzunehmen und nicht zurückzutreten, wenn ich dann zu Hause bin und meine Frau fragt mich irgendwie, wir brauchen noch gar kein Auto, oder was weiß ich, was man sich da für ein Signal überlegt. Es gibt, wenn ich mir nicht selbst daran beteiligt war, zu diesem Runterhandeln zu kommen, dann gibt es bei mir einen Druck, nicht mehr davon zurückzutreten.
Ja, und vor allem ist es auch ein Erfolgserlebnis für dich.
Es ist ein Erfolgserlebnis, aber es gibt auch B dieses Gefühl, ich habe daran mitgewirkt, das wäre unanständig, wenn ich davon jetzt zurücktrete.
Teil meiner Arbeit sozusagen, also meiner Arbeitsleistung.
Ich habe mitgewirkt, und das gibt es in der Politik selbstverständlich auch. Man lässt halt alle möglichen Leute an irgendwelchen Gesetzentwürfen mitarbeiten, und dann können sie am Ende nicht dagegen stimmen, was sie mitgewirkt haben. Selbst wenn es überhaupt nichts mit dem Thema, weswegen sie auf Seite 500 mitgewirkt haben, und der schlimme Teil ist, spielt keine Rolle, das ist einfach ein psychologisches Problem, was es gibt und was ausgenutzt wird. Es gibt natürlich auch diesen Effekt, dass sich sowas abnutzt. Also einer der außerhalb der Politik am besten funktionierenden Sachen, um Leute zu beeinflussen, ist, wenn man irgendeine Autorität befragt. Ja, ein Professor, einen Experten, einen Sachverständigen. Und das ist in der Politik inzwischen so weit verbreitet, dass einfach jeder mit 20 Experten aufschlägt, die alle das Gegenteil behaupten, dass das nicht mehr funktioniert. Ja, also nicht alle von diesen Sachen sind tatsächlich 100 Prozent erfolgreich. Und einige nutzen auch ab. Aber man muss sich dessen vergewärtigen, vergegenwärtigen, was da so für Tricks verwendet werden gegen die Leute. Und man muss verstehen, dass die Korruption ansetzt, nachdem alle diese Tricks schon auf jemanden eingewirkt haben. Das heißt, der zu überwindende Schritt ist ein ganz kleiner Winde, weil man schon den fast zu weit hat, dass er ja sagt.
Die Korruption ist nur noch der letzte Schubs, um sicherzustellen, dass es irgendwie funktioniert.
Genau. Und deswegen kann man mit kleineren Sachen größere Dinge erreichen. Mit relativ kleinen Parteischmänden kriegt man ja bei der FDP auch schon diese Hoteliers-Sachen losgetreten.
Ja, stimmt.
Also das klärt sich, wenn man diese psychologischen Tricks mal gesehen hat, dass es überhaupt nicht darauf ankommt, jetzt da die Milliarden rauszuholen, sondern es reicht schon, um so eine Art freundschaftlichen Rapport zu erzeugen, reicht schon eine relativ kleine Spende. Und damit die Leute sich verpflichtet fühlen, das zurückzugeben.
Diese Parteispendennummer ist natürlich auch einfach so ein Ding, wo man genau hingucken muss, weil die kann man eben nur als Indikator basierend auf dieser Erkenntnis, dass sie eben nur der letzte Schubs ist, nur als Indikator dafür benutzen, wo es noch weitergehende Beziehungen gibt. Also da muss man dann eben genauer hingucken, wenn man so Parteispenden sieht. So auf welchen Festen waren die gemeinsam, was haben die noch gesponsert, haben die Studien beigetragen, sind Leute von den Ministerien. Das heißt also, man kann diese Parteispenden eben nur als Liste von Interessenten, die halt den letzten Schubs getan haben, nehmen, nicht aber als für die 50.000 haben sich diese und jenes gekauft. Das ist eine ganz wichtige Erkenntnis.
Ja, was ich auch noch einen wichtigen Punkt finde, ist, dass diese ganzen Mechanismen kommen ja nicht aus der Politik, sondern die sind genauso in der Wirtschaft verbreitet. Also es gibt ja zig Zahlungen, die die meisten Leute überhaupt nicht verstehen, dass sie im Hintergrund getätigt werden. Im Supermarkt zum Beispiel zahlen die Hersteller dafür, dass ihre Produkte da stehen und zwar je besser der Platz, an dem sie stehen. Da gibt es auch Psychologen, die sich damit beschäftigen. Zum Beispiel, wenn in Bodennähe sehen es halt die meisten Leute nicht oder es ist weniger attraktiv, dafür wird gezahlt, handfest von den Herstellern. Deswegen, dass bestimmt welche Marken da stehen. Das sind deswegen immer dieselben riesigen Firmen, die da platziert sind und sich die kleinen Firmen das nicht leisten können.
Na ja und andersherum halt in den Buchläden zum Beispiel müssen die Verlage dafür zahlen, dass sie eben an die entsprechenden Positionen kommen bzw. eben präsentiert werden als Tipp des Tages und sowas. Also das ist eben genau derselbe Mechanismus, den du da erwähnt hast mit den Kellnern und den Trinkgeldern, die halt eben, also diese Mechanismen werden überall verwendet. Man muss eben nur die Augen aufmachen und gucken, wo sie sind.
Ja, also ich finde es auch wichtig, dass wir das mal ein bisschen ansprechen, weil die meisten Leute verstehen das gar nicht. Wenn ich zum Beispiel in eine fremde Stadt gehe und den Taxifahrer bitte, er soll mich mal zum guten Hotel fahren oder in einen schönen Club, dann kriegt er Geld von dem Club oder Hotel dafür, dass er mich dahin fährt. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie verbreitet das in Deutschland ist, aber in England und Amerika ist das absolut üblich. In Frankreich, ich weiß auch, in Deutschland würde ich auch davon ausgehen, dass das so ist. Die Bücher hast du angesprochen, ganz verbreitet ist das auch in der Musikindustrie gewesen. Da ist es dann immer noch natürlich, aber in der Musikindustrie gab es da richtig fette Verfahren in Amerika gegen die Musikfirmen. Die haben ja erst gegen die Radios gekämpft, so nach dem Motto, die machen uns unsere Absetzmärkte kaputt. Und dann haben sie das verstanden, wie das funktioniert. Und haben angefangen, die Radiosender dafür zu bezahlen, dass sie ihre Songs spielen. Und das nennt sich Periola. Das könnt ihr mal verlinken. Bei der Wikipedia, das war ein handfester Skandal vor vielen Jahren. Natürlich ist das heute immer noch so. Das ist einfach PR, da wird gezahlt, natürlich. Und ein anderer Punkt, der ähnlich funktioniert, also jetzt Trinkgelder, ist ja eine Sache, die man zusätzlich zahlt. Es gibt natürlich auch Trinkgelder in die Gegenrichtung. Wenn man zum Beispiel so etwas sieht wie ein billig Brokerage, so ein Aktienhändler, der keine Gebühren nimmt pro Transaktion, der verdient natürlich trotzdem. Der macht das dann halt so, dass er die Aktie hintenrum bei einer Börse für ein bisschen Aufschlag verscheuert und den Aufschlag kriegt er zur Hälfte ausgezahlt von seinem Broker. So was nennt sich Kickback. Es gibt da Dutzende von Euphemismen und Ausdrucken für irgendwelche Kickbackzahlungen und wie sich die Leute gegenseitig die Kohle zuschieben. Also guckt euch mal Kickback an oder genauso ist es, wenn am Flughafen steht, wir tauschen das Geld und nehmen keine Gebühren dafür, dann kriegt man einen schlechteren Kurs. Also das ist in der Politik ein Problem, aber genauso überall sonst im Leben. Und wir können das in der Politik meines Erachtens auch nicht wegkriegen, wenn wir das sonst überall drüben. Auch diese, wenn ich einen Drucker kaufe, dass ich dann nicht über den Drucker abgezockt werde, sondern über die Tintenkosten, das ist ja genauso eine Scheiße. Bait und Switch nimmt man das früher, wenn man so tut, als wenn man hier ein tolles Angebot hat und dann aber eigentlich an anderer Stelle sich die Kohle reinholt oder an die Handys hat man sich ja inzwischen gewöhnt, dass ein Handy einen Euro kostet, dass man halt über den Vertrag abgezockt wird. Das ist ja auch eigentlich letztendlich eine Form von Korruption. Man wird dazu mit dem Geschenk eines günstigen Handys dazu gebracht, sich den beschissenen Handyvertrag zu akzeptieren.
Interessant finde ich auch, dass die Bestätigung, dass es eben wenn es alle anderen tun, dass solche Verhaltensweisen dann schon okay sind, dass die dann eben auch eine gravierende Rolle spielen. Also diese soziale Bestätigung, ja eben in der Politik genau dasselbe ist wie im normalen Leben. Wenn alle anderen zu dieser Partie gehen oder rauchen oder dies oder jenes tun, dann tut man es eben auch. Also dann ist es halt irgendwie normal und akzeptiert und führt halt zu keinen negativen Folgen. Und in der Politik ist ja genau dasselbe. Also wenn halt die Leute in den Aufsichtsräten sitzen oder halt mit der Fraktion stimmen, also dem Fraktionszwang folgen, dann ja, dann müssen sie es ja offenbar richtig machen. Also dann sind sie ja nicht gegen den Mainstream.
Es kann sogar zu so einem Statussymbol werden. Wenn, sag ich mal, der Maschmeier oder wie auch immer, das ist in Hannover, da immer seine Ausstattend-Partys feiert, dann ist natürlich derjenige, der da teilnimmt, privilegiert gegenüber dem, der nicht eingeladen wurde. Also man muss einfach verstehen, was das für ein breites Problem ist und nicht nur so zwei, drei schwarze Schafe, die da irgendwie rummarodieren, sondern es ist ein richtig breites, tiefes Problem in der gesamten Bevölkerung. Und wir müssen uns dem ganzheitlich widmen und nicht nur irgendwie auf die drei Leute zeigen, die erwischt wurden.
Naja, wir haben jetzt nun eine Partei, die irgendwie angetreten ist, um all dies zu ändern, nämlich die Piraten. Du hattest dich ja irgendwie länglich im Block mit denen auseinandergesetzt.
Fehlt uns jetzt so ein bisschen die Zeit, gerade dann auch darauf herum zu bashen. Aber das können wir ja auch noch mal machen.
Genau, da werden wir, glaube ich, dann einfach nächstes Mal drüber reden entgegen der Ankündigung. Wir sind soweit durch. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und wie gesagt, der Flatter-Button ist auf der Seite, wenn ihr Lust dazu habt. Ansonsten lohnt es uns dann im Zweifel, auch die Links durchzuklicken dazu. Und wir hoffen, dass wir das nächste Mal nicht so lange brauchen, weil wir jetzt doch jetzt wieder ein funktionsfähiges Recording Setup haben, auch für Intercontinental Podcasts, dass wir den nächsten doch etwas schneller liefern können als den davor. Und ansonsten vielen Dank für's Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.